I had the same problem I've seen some of
the countryside I hadn't seen for an
awful long time
let's make a start if we may I will
welcome to welcome you to the baby
planning committee I will now ask the
government's officer to read out the
domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations for you thank you Claire
thank you chair
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking if you're attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptop is also switched to silent we'll
be using the e-voting for this meeting
on the modern gov app so please give
members make sure they are logged in and
ready to use the app
fire safety Arrangements if you hear the
fire alarm leave the building
immediately via a fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point which is
Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium ground floor area
and walkways if you are in the atrium at
the time of the alarm follow the signs
to the nearest fire exit use the stairs
not the lifts and do not re-enter the
building until told it is safe to do so
the council members of the public and
the Press may be called film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded thank you
officers on his way
the area planning manager is around
somewhere I think he's trying to find
the chief planning officer oh he's
up there Mark's up there okay Mark and
Dupree our legal advisor
and the case officer is Vincent Price
thank you
can I move to the agenda yes right
um positive absence and substitution do
we have any apologies for absence
thank you chair we have apologies from
councilor Lee Jameson and councilor
Robert Lindsay is substituting
received declarations procure your
interest other register school and
non-registerable interests by members
are there any
counselor hold
yes sorry um I've had some previous
involvement in this site however I can
confirm I'm approaching this planet
decision that I combined and base my
decision on the balance of facts
presented
thank you Council councilor Osborne
yeah thank you Mr chairman yeah I'm um a
Sudbury Town councilor in respect of the
application we're reading today but I
know um
pecuniary interest uh and we'll listen
with the debate thank you
thank you
councilor Owen
oh yeah there you go thank you very much
um uh yeah Subway Town councilor also
and obviously
um no peculiar interests
um
and obviously my view is different okay
thank you thank you
anyone else
no
all right moving on confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting Helga in August
it's
2022.
only points of accuracy regarding these
minutes
nope
cancel that BuzzFeed
uh May
in relation to a comment I had about
the sugar wheat site and
extra access
and the planning officer was going to
get back to me according to the minutes
and they haven't
so do you want to change to the minutes
or do you want an update from the area
like the planning officer to get back to
me
oh but there's no correction to the
minutes
correction to the minutes
thank you councilor hold yeah for my
site chair this is the third time this
item has been brought up for committee
and the Planned officer is yet to come
back to us I think it's time he did
thank you we get these out the way and
we can look at it
fine
in that case
can I have a proposal for accepting the
minutes councilor Osborne can I have a
second there
councilor mccrore
the government's officer will now
conduct the electronic vote
that vote should now be in progress
councilman beer can I take your vote
please four thank you and councilor
Lindsay
thank you
thank you chair that's one abstention
and ten votes for that's carried
thank you
minutes have been confirmed and will be
signed
moving on
[Music]
confirmation of the minutes held on the
24th of August 2022
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
[Music]
nope in that case can I have a proposer
councilor Barrett thank you can I have a
secondary councilor Osborne
governance officer will now conduct
another votes
[Music]
four thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you chair again that is
10 votes for and one extension thank you
Mr Bean past and they will be signed
receive notifications petitions in
accordance to the council's petition
schemes governance officer
we have
we have a dc2106519
petitioner has a total of 23 verified
signatures a previous position was
received with a total of 249 names
whether this was rejected as there was
no signatures included
in addition to this a digital list of
813 representations was also received
the petition reads as follows
we the undesigned wish to petition
against the development of the former
swimming pool at the site at Bellevue
Park in Sudbury into a multi-story block
of 42 living units by Churchill
retirement living and to the development
of Bellevue house into two private
dwellings by McCabe and Abel neither of
these developments offer affordable
housing which is in chronic short supply
Churchill's planning application removes
existing pedestrian access to the park
from the Town Center
the former swimming pool skate park site
is open space as defined by the ocean
space Act of 1906. the government's
National planning policy framework
states that open space Recreation land
should not be built on unless an
assessment shows the space to be Surplus
to requirements
this is not the case at Bellevue
baber's own 2019 open space
assessment highlighted concerns over the
substantial 24 acre deficit of Park and
recreational land in Sudbury Sudbury
needs more open space of this kind and
cannot afford to lose nor Bellevue house
is a much loved part of sudbury's
history and was a Community Asset used
by the public through a wide variety of
purposes over many years it is neither
fitting nor respectful to sell it to
just two families
there are serious issues about the
increased traffic flow resulting from
further development as sudbury's busiest
Junction poor accessibility of these
sites and the detrimental effect from
the environment of the Town Center thank
you Chad
thank you Claire
chairman could I just ask the officer if
she could tell me the numbers again I
didn't quite get that please okay so the
petition had a total of 23 verified
signatures 23 yes previous position was
received with a total of 249 names
however this was rejected as there were
no signatures included in addition to
this a digital list of 813
representations was also received
so it's nearly 1100 or if you add them
up thank you
thank you
do we have a request for a site
inspection
Mr Mark Russell here would you present
your request
thank you chair
um this
this is a variation of condition
application for the above mentioned
planning application for 100 houses at
tamage Road Acton the case office of
this is Elizabeth flood she's unable to
be with us today so I'll run you through
a few slides to call in for the site
visit came from councilor none
oops
I'll start at the end then sorry I put
it in the wrong place
um the question at hand is a an
alteration to the Subspace and
so this very rough schematic here shows
what is being proposed
the three sub basins to think about the
first one is the one that got permission
originally back in 2020 the second is
what's on site at the moment there have
been reports that have been having water
in it Etc and the third is the one
they're actually applying for at the
moment which is depicted by the
schematic in front of you
I'll briefly give you some some figures
to go with it the original studs Basin
was to have been a one in four gradient
um with a sediment four bay at the
southern end
propose sad Basin would not have a
sediment for Bay but would have flow
channels instead
proposed that the there would be soil
above granular material at the bottom uh
which would be planted not the bottom so
the size that we planted with Wild Flour
mix
slopes of the Basin would remain at one
in four but would be longer than the
ones that you gave permission for in
2020.
at the Eastern end of the slope from the
children's plate area to the bottom of
the Basin would be approximately 9.5
meters
the land around the Basin has also been
raised
slopes down to the Basin although at the
same angle as approved would be longer
by about 3.3 meters
proposed before you is just for
variation of condition two which relates
to drawings so the drawing you're seeing
in front of you and others relating to
the suds are the issue at hand the
applicant did
such Basin which wasn't the one they had
permission for so there was a breach of
planning control our enforcement team
had been involved and this is a
partially retrospective application
just to remind you of the site itself
it's to the south of Thomas Road Acton
and it's actually being built out at the
moment at the moment as you can see
that's the scheme when it's completed
and the Subspace and in question is to
the
to the north here around here just there
the play area being next to it
those uh chair I think are all the
slides I've got and the request oh here
we are that's what it looked like before
the request was by councilor nun to have
a site visit I know members have been
there before but the request was made
because topography has has changed a bit
and the councils would like you to
actually have a look at what it looks
like now
thank you Mark
any questions for the officer councilor
Baron
thank you
Council McCall
and I'm just not certain what we're
going to gain from trying to imagine
different depths of a drainage basin a
hole Yeah and trying to imagine a hole
with a different depths with a different
slope I'm not sure what's to be gained
by a physical and a physical site visit
when basically the diagrams and site
levels should tell us everything we we
need to know
thank you Council Robin obviously
there's a law I live in Acton and
there's a hell of a lot being done in
Acton
um
I believe if it's going anywhere near
the play area if it's getting bigger I
think we do need to look at
look at it um that's that's reason
enough isn't it
thank you it won't take us that long
councilor hold
I don't see the point of attention to be
honest just like some reassurance from
the planning officer that if the surface
area of the hole is going to be larger
eye deeper and wider that measures put
in place of the safety of children
playing nearby and previous applications
has been given due consideration and
that any necessary
any necessary steps are taken to ensure
that the site is safe for children to
play close to I don't think we need to
go and see it
I think we're getting into the merits of
the case the account so I can say that
is is Ross per accredited which is the
that's what measures whether it's safe
or not so rosper have approved
thanks for the beer
um well I take a different view I think
it is the local members have asked for
this site inspection and there is the
play area that's in that vicinity and uh
we're gonna have water we know what
those two added together can cause
um I I think the amount of time it will
take us in that it will be well worth it
so I would support us go and have a look
on this occasion thank you
answer buzz me
roughly can we can we estimate how many
days a year there's likely to be water
in this pond
I don't have that information
unfortunately and for various sources
having read through that there are some
conflicting uh variations
um that their claim is that there
shouldn't be water uh and they've
described it as
um
it was to be a sedimentary for Bay now
it'd be uh it would have flow channels
instead so from that I take it there
could be rivulets of water rather than
an area of standing water but I cannot
guarantee that's the case counselor
question for me what will we gain from
doing a business
the councilor was concerned that the
topography had changed so not only would
the Subspace and be deeper and the
surrounding areas also been lifted up
somewhat by the movement of soil around
the site
so I think that's what council want to
look at
thank you
if there's no more questions can I have
a proposal that we have a site visit
what do you wish to do
all right
fine do we have a second
thanks for the hold thank
you thank you
that's right
so members your vote reads that a site
visit should not be undertaken so the
vote four would be to not go on a five
percent
[Applause]
so your vote is
a site visit should not be undertaken in
respect of application number
dc2201674 so if you are voting for you
are voting to not visit if you were
voting against you were voting to visit
councilor beer okay
against
councilor Lindsay
thank you members chair that is 10 votes
sorry eight votes four and three votes
against so therefore there will not be a
site visit undertaken thank you very
much
yes councilman
I don't suppose this will come back to
you wouldn't
um can I suggest
that we ask for some kind of barrier
between the play area and the suds
can you believe that's the intention
councilman I will speak to the case
officer about that
thank you
thank you
moving on to schedule a planning
applications we have
dc2106519 Bellevue house and all
swimming pool Newton Road Sudbury
I will now invite the case officer if
it's a pierce to interruptcy introduce
the application to the committee
and clarification and it's got on many
papers case officer Bradley Hesse and
we've got Vincent here
um can you explain why well we'll ask
Vincent to explain why
chairman good morning members guests and
anyone who may be watching or listening
to this online I'm here today on behalf
of Bradley heifer because unfortunately
he's not
I'm standing in as I did
but I do know the site I have visited
the site and I've discussed it
extensively with
press morning
with your permission chair may I yes
thank you as the chairman said we're
looking at dc21065
which is the construction of 41
apartments for retirement living
and the conversion and refurbishment of
Bellevue house into two dwellings
are we going to get the magic music
every time that button's pressed
foreign
please carry on and if you can lose it
please do
so the application is within the ward of
Sudbury Southwest as you can see from
the next slide
it's the Confluence of three Wards but
it is actually
in Southwest just south of Newton Road
as I always say this presentation is but
one of the considerations you have to
take into account and it does not
supplant or replace the comprehensive
report that you have in the agenda what
I do need to say is this presentation
actually supersedes and replaces that
previously given
as you may recall it worsted so we're
asking you to start afresh with the
consideration of this
application
I also have to say for the sake of
transparency that the site
is or was owned by
the council
but the application is being promoted by
Churchill retirement living
so just so there's no doubt the council
has an interest insofar as it is also in
a way related to the park entrance
improvements that you considered
previously and resolved to Grant
permission
the report sets out perfectly
extensively the range of
we've received worth noting that Sudbury
Town Council recommended refusal
the Bellevue Action Group strongly
objects and you'll have received
representations the Sudbury Society
generally supports the proposal
as it will restore Bellevue house
that they urge the council to ensure
that those works are carried out
and not left to chance once and
a retirement living scheme has been
developed
as clear
announced at the starting meeting there
have been a number of
missions and players update super seats
whatever I might say on that
screen clears is the latest update
just for those who aren't particularly
familiar with Sudbury sits to the west
of
switch
and to the west of of Hadley
we're looking at the red site on this
map at the Eastern end of King Street it
represents the Eastern end of Sudbury
town center and it sits at the point
where Newton Road and cornard Road beat
at the roundabout at the Eastern end of
King Street
aerial view there you see it in in
context
I do need to quickly run through some
policy matters to help you in your
consideration this application
first thing to note is that within the
adopted local plan 2006 the site is
allocated
largely for mixed use purposes there is
a pocket of the um
site that you'll see
etched black
which is part of Bellevue Park
the majority of the site sits in an area
where mixed use
to be promoted and encouraged now you
may say well what does that actually
mean what is mixed use in planning terms
and we get some strong clues in the
local plan itself
so policy sdo2 says that in the mixed
use area
General Industry is not acceptable
sdo3 indicates that small-scale rear
tail would be acceptable within the
mixed use area so we know that retail
might be acceptable
sd04 actually states that residential
development
is acceptable provided it has no adverse
effect on the vitality and viability of
the Town Center
so in terms of the allocated use in the
local plan residential this proposal is
a residential proposal and is therefore
by its very nature acceptable within the
allocated mixed use area
in those terms it is policy compliant
one of the elements that of this case
that I need to highlight is that the
scheme does not deliver any affordable
housing
now you might say well that's unusual
why isn't a residential scheme
delivering affordable housing and the
answer is
that as part of the evidence base for
the joint local plan
the council has taken the line on advice
from its viability Consultants
that schemes such as this specialist
elderly housing are not viable
if they have to contribute to affordable
housing then you may say well
how do we know that's true Mr Pierce
where does that come from
so
the point I would pick out here is the
plan viability and civil review study
from October 2020 particularly at
paragraph 8.3 which says older person's
accommodation is unviable
with naughty percent affordable housing
and all other policies including Sill
we recommend that this type of
development is zero rated fossil and no
affordable how is sold
so that's the premise that has
underpinned the jlp going forward now we
know that the jlp at the moment has
carried it carries little weight and
that we are continuing to proceed with
towards its adoption at least in part
one
council's position at the moment is
underpinned in this case this particular
Case by that evidence base
the taken on behalf of the council
you'll see that the prospective seal
rates actually carried forward that
recommendation the council would not be
proposing to charge Sill
on a scheme that comprised elderly
accommodation
this plan simply shows the
pose development the area in blue cross
hatching is where the existing entrance
to the park is and the crosstatched
green area is an area that's currently
active open space beside
park it forms part of the park
now we have to we have to look at a
number of definitions because as you've
seen from representation as there is a
disagreement between some of the
objectives and the advice that we are
giving you as officers and I want to be
clear what our position is
I'm sure
Representatives will be before you this
morning will make their case the first
definition we need to look at is what is
open space in terms of the nppf
open space is defined as all open space
of public value including not just land
but also areas of water such as Rivers
canals lakes and reservoirs which offer
important opportunities for sport and
Recreation
and connect as visual immunity
I'll come back to the relevance of that
in a moment
the next point we have to try and get to
grips with is previously developed land
and I think previously I might have well
describe some parts of this site as
previously developed land which used to
be known as Brownfield land but if we go
back to the source definition in the
mppf I will read it verbatim previously
developed land is land which is or was
occupied by a permanent structure
including the cartilage of the developed
land although it should not be assumed
that the whole of the cartilage should
be developed and any Associated fixed
surface infrastructure
this excludes land that is or was last
occupied by and I jumped to the dark
text parks Recreation grounds and land
that was previously developed but where
the remains of the permanent structure
of fixed structure
blended into the landscape
I think you'll hear from
which is that in their opinion the old
swing pool site
is not previously
developed land because in their view it
was part of a park or Recreation ground
and that is in fact open space
I also need to dwell in some detail into
paragraph 99 because this sits at the of
the mppf this sits at the heart of the
debate
and this is where the government talked
about promoting healthy and safe
communities so paragraph 99 opens with
distinct open space Sports and
recreational buildings and land
including Playing Fields should not be
built on unless
so if you were to take the view that the
objectives have this site actually
represents open space possibly even
Sport and recreation building then that
is suggesting
that it should not be lost
unless
first criteria an assessment has been
undertaken which has clearly shown the
open space buildings or land to be
Surplus to requirements
you'll notice that's followed by or it's
not and
oh
next
two requirements the loss resulting from
the proposed development would be
replaced
by equivalent or better provision in
terms of the quantity or quality
in a suitable location
now in resolving to Grant planning
permission for the park entrance and the
associated works
as officers we are recommending to you
that that actually qualifies as Part B
of paragraph
89
the loss of that green area that we
showed earlier
has been more than adequately
compensated or will be more than
adequately compensated for by
the park entrance and the associated
works
part C the development is for
alternative Sports and recreational
provision the benefits of which clearly
outweigh the loss of the current former
use
we'll come back to the fact that when it
was a an open-air swimming pool when it
closed it
closed at the point at which the council
had provided a new swimming pool
a larger and better indoor swimming pool
the Kingfisher pool
just to the South
it had been replaced at that time by
alternative facilities
so
whether or not it is or isn't open space
or previously developed land as officers
we are saying the proposal actually
qualifies
within paragraph 99b because
if you were to Grant this permission
it's predicated on the park entrance
details being
emptied
suggested a section 106 that ties the
two together
I'll come into more detail on that
just quickly looking at your
report and the recommendation I've
highlighted here at what in your agenda
appears as bullet point three
the actual linking mechanism to which
we're suggesting
we can ensure that the retirement living
does not proceed until such time as the
park entrance details have been
in accordance with a program
so in that way we have safeguarded
delivery
off the park entrance and in that way
any loss of open space the park
ing site is adequately compensated for
of just quickly superimposed over the
top there the scheme that you saw last
time in resolve to Grant permission
leaves you with a reminder of the
current allocated
for the site
in terms of constraints
the site itself is
adjacent to Sudbury
Town Center Conservation Area
there are a number of listed buildings
well not the number a large number of
listed buildings to the West including
grade one grade two star and grade two
listed buildings
excuse me so that's the extent of the
Conservation Area
but we also have to take into account
are the fact that Bellevue house itself
whilst not statutorily or listed
is considered
to be locally listed in terms of its
importance within the local
community that gives it an added layer
of protection above most properties but
not
same level of protection as the
buildings might have
also nearby we have one to six cornard
road that aren't particularly affected
by the proposal that's before this
morning so we're concentrating on
Bellevue
and the important thing to note about
this application is that it will deliver
the retention of Bellevue house it will
deliver its refurbishment
it will deliver its conversion and it
will deliver continued residential use
at the moment as you know it's vacant
there has been doubt over the future of
Bellevue house and I think the fact that
Sudbury Civic Society
support the proposal is that it will at
last
ensure the longevity of Bellevue house
as a feature within the
landscape hereabouts and the townscape
there aren't any flooding issues to
consider within this application
I do need to quickly consider the status
of the site and its surroundings as
whether or not they constitute
assets of community value because I did
much on that previously
and it's important to note that
Bellevue Park itself is registered
successfully as an asset of community
value
the actual old swimming pool and
Bellevue house itself
not successful in being registered as
assets of community value
so the site itself
is not a registered Community Asset
here we have an old map from 1887 where
you can see Bellevue house
sitting at that point and you'll notice
to the left
or the left and end of that oval there
are a cluster of buildings that hug the
corner
cornard Road
so in 1887 there was a strong built
presence to that Frontage
here's a shot from the early 20th
century so the blue dot is what was the
old police station
King Street you can see Bellevue Park
behind it and then a range of
what we're at the time
locally important elements within the
Town Center you've got the old Brewery
the yellow Dot
the Old Timber yard with the brown Dot
and of course the station that's still
there in with the Green Dot the point
I'm trying to emphasize with this
picture is
that end of Sudbury did have a strong
built form wrapping around the corner
with Bellevue park behind it so here we
have a shot of the police station the
list the buildings on the left most of
which remain clearly the police station
no longer exists
sorry
yeah so
the
person with the bicycle
if they were looking towards that
building the three-story building they
would be looking towards Bellevue Park
which sits behind that so that's the
Eastern end
King Street on the left
is Newton Road
and just to the right would be cornard
Road
so there's a shop with the police
station on the corner
the buildings you see in the background
are still there
so I show you what they look like
today
I've tried to merge
current and passed images to give you an
idea of how prominent that police
station was
now what I've I said previously was that
I gave the impression that actually that
police station was actually further
towards Bellevue Park and this gives me
a chance to correct that
so there you can see on the old
map from 1926 on the corner
cluster of buildings the police station
is the building
cornard Road
what happened was
in recent past the police station was
demolished to make way for Highway
improvements that include the existing
roundabouts if I quickly show
that is what was the old swimming pool
as you can see on the aerial view
has gone and there's a big roundabout
there
so in essence what happened was
the police station was demolished to
make way for the highway works of the
shown in red
so there was a pocket of old police
station site
that actually is now the land in front
of the existing wall
so no part of the application site
formed what was the old free station
light blue
which is where the open air pool was
saying at the moment whether any of that
constitutes Brownfield land previously
developed land at all
really highlighting the historic
progression of developments on the on
the site
Bellevue house itself
was a a rebuild of an earlier Georgian
rather handsome property a bow fronted
property that was probably more stylish
however with changing fashion
the owner in 1872 decided to rebuild in
the form that you currently see it
so the bow fronted Georgian building
went and we have what is a typically
High Victorian large house
looking on to
um
ornamental grounds and the park
taking this video from the
internet and you'll see the references
there but it quickly takes you
to fly through so that you get a much
better idea of
just how attractive Bellevue house is
interesting detail there's the brackets
under the extended Eaves
it is in its own writer An Elegant
Victorian
dwelling and I think it actually adds to
the character of the area it certainly
gives context to the park
and it is important that we have managed
to save it
potentially from
Demolition and potentially from
dereliction I'm not saying it's in any
way
elect at the moment he's boarded up it
is in good condition
though that actually gives you quite a
nice idea of the context
the back and you'll notice that Bellevue
that sits on an area of raised
ground it's almost on a on a grassy
plinth
shots in the old pool
before 19 I think it was 39 people used
to publicly bathe in the river stir
the open air Lido Lido was created
and actually went on until
the 1980s when the new Kingfisher pool
was created
it's now being filled in and is
generally derelict
Paul the new pool as was shown in yellow
so what happened was is the open air
pool
effectively
change locations into a larger indoor
pool replaced the existing facilities
here we've got a short section of video
just to show you
what was the old pool clearly you can
see it's been filled in
in a reasonably unkempt
state
quite untidy it's a bit scruffy
shot over the wall
Park entrance and clearly
many of the objectives have expressed
concern at the closure of this access
in the event that you grant planning
permission for the retirement living
scheme but of course
the new park entrance is designed to be
prominent it is it is designed to be
highly accessible
and uh
research has shown in the recent past
that visitors to Sudbury do not
necessarily know how to access
Bellevue Park itself part of the
rationale for the new entrance is to
make a very prominent public statement
about
the park
so we've had a quick shot there that's
beside the entrance
part of the old pool structure
the roundabout and
an interesting condition bits have been
patched up with concrete there's some
bits where replacement brick has been
put in
clear that the wall was heightened at
some time possibly as part of the open
air pool to provide extra security I
don't know
the majority of the old pool site is
enclosed by a wall
there is a section of fencing
so there we have the section within the
park where it's Timber fencing with
Gates
in and through over the wall
the interesting thing to note about this
site is there is a
significant change in levels the land
rises from the roundabout to the East
and that's important in terms of
actually disguising the Balkan scale of
the proposed
new building the retirement living so on
that shot you'll notice
it rises in that direction
and Rises towards Bellevue house
so at that point the difference in
levels is some set meters
a lidar image here
shows we can get this here you'll notice
the raised plinth Earth plinth that
Bellevue house sits on also within the
part there's a clear bit of terracing in
here what this doesn't necessarily show
is is that actual increase in
ingredient through here
okay
let's highlighting me also
close proximity to this side is is easy
access to the range of Riverside walks
that lie in the stir
so I've just taken a selection of shots
of access points into the trails that
that follow the stir from this end of of
Sudbury so there's really good access to
open
from the site
and again just to remind members this is
the
Park entrance detail the resolved to
approve last time the time we met
superimposed over what was the old
swimming pool so you can see the large
part of the old supreme pool will be
occupied by the entrance details
some reminders of the shots just how
just had entrance
will be
it's a real statement and civic pride of
to Sudbury and just how important that
Park is that the council actually wants
to make something of the entrance and
draw people to it
when they visit
the town
important thing to notice this scheme is
essentially
two elements the retention of Bellevue
house shown in purple
and the construction of a
41 apartment retirement living scheme
which is shown in white
so
sit in footprint
the current extension of that end of the
building will be demolished
so that when you compare what will be if
you grant permission to the 90 so the
1885 version it actually restores
Bellevue house much to its original
size and and appearance
so the later Edition will be removed
there will be a modest bit of extension
at that end of the
so in a way it brings Bellevue house
much much closer to its original
appearance
the entrance point to the site will be
from Newton Road at the point indicated
by the yellow triangle and this is
important to um
because
once you're in the site you then gain
access to the two dwellings that are the
conversion of
Bellevue house
at the moment
the red area represents the area within
which you can maneuver a vehicle in and
out
and as you can see it's poorly defined
it's a it's quite an open area where a
whole range of movements can happen in
close proximity to what is a reasonably
complex Junction
so actually this proposal will
rationalize that entrance and actually
Channel traffic into it into safer
movements
so if we take a look so here we're
standing in Newton Road Council agency
and we're looking Woods back towards the
Town Center
King Street in the distance and we've
got that large area that I showed him
red before on your left so just to the
left is is
you might say is the hidden entrance to
the
Park well the first thing you'll notice
is the
poor condition of the road surface
you'll notice the existing curb that
wraps around the corner
you'll notice that if you followed the
line of the curb
in the foreground
takes you to a point where
back behind what is the footway nib to
cross the road so if you were
standing there you're actually beginning
to stand out in the road it isn't well
defined there's a lot of
potential conflict between different
users of the footway the park the road
and it could do with rationalizing
actually they can provide all the
necessary visibility space that enter
County Council as Highway Authority have
confirm they are satisfied with that
arrangement
there it is in a bit more detail
but I also want to show you that
movements in and out of the site have
been carefully considered and these have
all been checked by our colleagues at
Suffolk County Council so on the left
shows you how you would enter the site
in your car if you were traveling along
Newton Road towards the Center and how
you would leave if you wanted to leave
towards the Town Center
on the right it shows you what you would
be doing if you're entering from the
right or leaving to the right
fairly Orthodox and straightforward
traffic maneuver
in a clearly defined
enter and leaving forward gear which is
always the referred way of
of maneuvering nobody wants to see a
vehicle reverse out onto a main road
fire engines can get in and out
safely
because I really need to emphasize with
this slide is that the scheme is not
delivering what you might consider your
normal parking
space
So within this scheme we have 16 spaces
basic and that's because Suffolk County
Council
as our Highway colleagues have accepted
that this type of development
generates lower
on-site parking demand lower car
ownership than ordinary residential
development
and this has been accepted at Point
this isn't uh
standard that's unique to Sudbury
it follows a case that
Suffolk County councils sought to defend
elsewhere within the county not within
our district
where an inspector accepted that
the time and living of this nature
inherently comes with fewer vehicles
is something that you'll see across the
country
a Churchill have argued 6
6 the fact that they've argued that
successfully in many locations doesn't
necessarily impress us
but the fact the fact that our
colleagues at Suffolk County Council are
satisfied arrangement
suggests to us that there isn't a
sustainable reason to refuse on the
grounds of inadequate
parking
sorry
so what about the appearance
so here is a
View
looking across let's say Newton
Road
so the lower
part of that on the right is actually
what it joins the roundabout and I draw
your particular attention to this end of
the development because this is where
the majority of the Amendments have been
secured over time certainly over the
lifetime of this application
if I superimpose
what originally came in you'll notice
that it was significantly higher one two
three four stories on that corner and if
I
flash back
you'll notice
not only have we secured the lowering of
the building at the Western end of the
site but we've actually secured a series
of steps
along the whole Frontage
in the area that is currently the war
that has made a dramatic
impact
in terms of the the
dominant or not of that building on that
corner
so here we have what is now proposed
you'll notice the building on the left
actually has a
hairs on apps so that is a curved
curved roof
so there's a series of buildings that
drop down
very clever way of disguising mass and
scale
that's a very strong vertical and
within the design
but notice
how that changed from what came in
originally
something that you might think is a bit
monolithic
now has
considerable
degree of detailing and
modulating in terms of heights and that
modulation of height is important in
terms of townscape
side view you won't ever see that
view where you to grant money permission
because Bellevue house sits in the
foreground
here's a view
from cornard Road within the park so you
see the rear of Bellevue house on the
right
and you see the series of roofs that
will be the retirement living unit
in the foreground in front of that will
be of course the new park entrance with
its stepped and ramped entrance
and again rather than have one big roof
spanning the whole of that building the
roof has been carefully broken down into
a series of smaller volumes
disguised the scale and mass of the
building
so just to emphasize how
we have
ensured that the building has been
broken up
deeply
we've managed to secure those three
elements
not only do they step back north to
south but of course they drop in scale
here's a shot
that you would see from Girling
Street a131
[Music]
then you notice just how important those
setbacks are in terms of breaking up the
scale of that building and then of
course this significant dropping in
height
what I've tried to do with this slide is
I'll quickly run through some of the
details that add to the quality of the
appearance of this building I haven't
identified them all but I've just given
you a flavor
so one we have dental Eaves molding
so there's some rather interesting
decorative features below the
create that rather
elegant overhang of the roof
very unusual to secure what is
I said earlier and apps so all of those
tart slates will be mitered and cut
so as to running a smooth curve so you
don't get any hips
you might otherwise get so if you had a
series of straight lines around that
curve you'd have a whole series of hips
running from the eaves to the back to
the ridge
which is a rather clunky
detail this is a very elegant and smooth
appearance
and as I say very unusual and very
difficult to secure within schemes
we've got horizontal Stone banding to
give emphasis
we've got the stone arches with recessed
detail behind
we've actually got stone lintels stone
Sills
and actually what I'm suggesting here is
that we secured cream gold rather than a
buff a yellowy buff we want to actually
want the traditional Suffolk cream
gold brick
we also want slate or an artificial
slate we don't want to see concrete
tiles we are on the edge of the
conservation area this is a very
prominent position at the
we want to see the quality of design
pushed in terms of the quality of
materials
does include brick reveals to Windows
we will be securing red stock bricks
which are traditional in
Suffolk where they wish to use red
again when it kill the wall that wraps
around this site
by condition we will be pushing for
English wall Bond not strict stretch a
bond to add to the character and quality
of that that wall
we will want to see the details of the
metal railings that will sit on top of
that wall because that's an important
component and a massive contribution to
the street scene
and also there is extensive Landscaping
on that
as well as the rest of the site
just highlighting the areas where that
type of material will be critical and
we'll
in terms of the floor plans what we have
on each level is a series of one-bed
apartments and two-bed apartments with
uh
common service areas and communal areas
shown in the light blue
you run through the building you'll see
that
there's a mix
existing floor plans for Bellevue house
very little is required in terms of
internal alteration to secure
division into two dwellings
it does
lend itself to a
a relatively simple split
so that blue line represents
where the
divide will be between the two dwellings
so in this area you'll you'll get a new
entrance
in this rather
interesting typically Victorian almost
like a
small sun room but that is an entrance
in here the main entrance will remain
for the house on the left hand side
look at all those details that we will
have secured the Lenten over the
the entrance all of those beautiful
brackets that will all be kept and
refurbished
now in terms of
height scale and mass here we have a
cross section through the town center so
Bellevue Park is just to the right of
that shot and you'll
the Magnificent Church on the the left
and there you notice how the land Rises
on the site
I'll zoom in close that red line will
move to show you
[Music]
show you top most part of the roof to
Bellevue house and you'll notice
that is actually higher than
any part of the roof on Bellevue
retirement living
result of the
significant drop in levels on the site
so here on the yellow arrow are the
three floors top of the
ceiling for the third floor down to the
ground floor
you slide that across
you'll notice that the additional story
has been accommodated at the bottom of
the slope rather than the building being
raised
and that's allowed us to drop that
building significantly
that's what allows it to see
Escape in the townscape on this part of
Sudbury Town Center
significant gap between the retained and
restored Bellevue house and the Eastern
end of the new building we got a gap of
21 meters down to
down to meters perfectly adequate Gap so
that the character of Bellevue house is
protected
I also have to draw your attention to
the fact that a number of trees on this
site will be lost if this development is
approved and you'll notice from the
report that our tree officer is
particularly High
shown green on here that would be
like all of these trees are considered
to be category B or C trees there aren't
any category a trees
to be lost
I don't want to underplay the extent of
tree loss
I didn't know whether counselor sorry
Vince could you go back
77 was it with the distances between the
two buildings
so
I don't understand what the 21 meter is
okay
so the 21 meters is from a flank wall
of the retirement living scheme
to the
two-story element within Bellevue which
so there okay so some spurious distance
in the air is nothing on the ground it
is I wouldn't say it's a spurious
distance in the air what I would say is
it marks the the point at which the the
main part of the retirement living block
is distanced from the main part of
Bellevue house what the blue line shows
is
from the foot of the single story
extension of Bellevue
to the Eastern end of the building so
what I didn't want to do is say that the
building is is only 14 meters
I wanted to show you the whole picture
so I would say there's perfect reason
for showing the distances that
I've showed you
moving on I I don't want to underplay
the three positions everything on in red
on that drawing is a tree
or scrub that will be lost
so at this end this is largely scrub
that partly overhangs the wall but there
are a whole series of trees in here
would be lost
where you might need to
I've shown them in brown here but what
I've also done is showing green all the
trees that are to be retained and of
course
what this doesn't show is all the tree
planting to the South within the park
and as part of part of Park entry
intra scheme
this shows a cross-section from
Crown house
on the north side of Newton Road
and the ridge line on the
living
units
Crown house actually makes a prominent
statement within the street scene
so here's a shot of the wall that I've
done for the purpose of this slide is
actually take out
Crown house just to show you so you can
see the impact it it makes itself
that is what you see already
that corner
was recently approved and is is now
complete or nearing completion
in terms of drainage the blue dots show
you where the surface water runs will go
and they're too
underground attenuating tanks and from
there they will feed into the existing
water system
foul water well again follow those roots
in black and end up
in the main sewage drain
Suffolk County Council flood and water
are satisfied with the
the arrangements and have indicated that
they have no objection
we also need to consider boundary
treatment what's being proposed in terms
of this the section A to B which is
adjoining the park would be a 1.1 meter
high metal railings on a low-level brick
wall
section B to C which would be provided
as part of the entrance Park entrance
works by the council would be a new
brick wall and this is the brick wall
that I'm suggesting ought to be in
English Bond and in good
vernacular red brick
what I'm also suggesting is somewhere
within that section
ought to be included the old swimming
pool
though sign
ought to be removed from where it is
saved and re
installed within the new boundary wall
to retain a link to the historic
reference to the old open air pool
section c to D again a low-level War
and the entrance
again further low-level Wars
I'm not so happy with the section e to F
and I am suggesting a condition that
that also
also all rather than
the
fence
I'm also suggesting that once you get
past the gate
that that section
ought to be a rule as well rather than
the timber fence
having gone to the
expense and care to retain and refurbish
Bellevue house it would seem a pity
to have a bit of Timber fencing to
separate it from
a retirement living block when
everything else is wall and railing
now in terms of the submission
the drawings appear to be silent in
terms of the boundary treatment along
with the northern and Eastern end
Bellevue house and the southern end
and that we need to condition and I am
recommending that we add conditions so
that we see all that boundary detail the
issue for us as
owners and operators of the park is
clearly we want the park to have
security so we wouldn't necessarily want
that boundary to be an open boundary
between Bellevue house and
by the same token
we'd have to accept that the residents
would want some degree of security
themselves and privacy
so the nature of that means of enclosure
is very important in terms of protecting
the character of Bellevue house the park
but also safe
amenity and preventing unauthorized
access to the park when the gates are
closed
there is a significant amount of energy
space for residents as
there is an extensive Landscaping
strategy and we are asking for further
detail by condition
Drake some of the key and
bearing in mind that some trees will be
lost as I've previously explained
we will see new tree planting in these
areas
and I think it might be a a good idea to
require those trees to be extra heavy
standards
so that they provide instant impact they
will take a lot more
short-term care and maintenance they
will have to be carefully looked after
but bearing in mind that we are losing
some established mature trees I think it
is right that we provide some instant
instant Greenery on the site Frontage to
help soften the initial impact of of the
built form being restored on this this
corner
within the site itself will be some
ornamental trees we'll see Evergreen
hedges in a number of key locations
particularly on the Newton Road
Frontage
be a whole host of smaller smaller
topiary specimens within the
site
we'll see some sculptural boundary trees
on on that element
Italian Cyprus which are tall
needle-like very architectural trees
and then across and around the site
there'll be a whole series of beds that
will be either ground cover native
shrubs ornamental shrubs
I've also added onto this sort of sorry
so here is the boundary with the
retirement living so here are the new
trees they are proposing but also the
council with its own scheme is taking
some tree planting on this part of the
the frontage within the what is
effective layer
Piazza paved Piazza with the entrance
leading into the
so there will be a lot of replacement
planting going on and of course within
the park itself they'll be additional
planting over time
try to on this slide I've created a
series of images where potentially you
could see what might happen when we
think about how to deal with that
boundary we could have something of
railings and it's a lower wall in the
same red brick
to create that
area of formality but also a sense of a
security for the residents
it could require that to be planted here
I've shown a beach hedge which
read during a lot of the year and in the
Autumn much of the winter it's the brown
leaf stay on the street but that could
be any sort of planting and then Within
the park itself within the ornamental
semicircular Garden of course the
council could plant a whole series of
ornamental beds if it wanted so that
might not be the final solution but what
I've tried to indicate is that it is
important that we carefully consider
that relationship between the two parts
of the
site the old house and the park
it can be done but I think it has to be
done elegantly
it has to be done in total keeping with
the Victorian feel of Bellevue house
we have a series of visualization so
here we are looking down Girling Street
as is
what you would see at the end of that
Vista
in terms of looking so you've got the
church behind you and you're looking
towards Bellevue Park along King Street
that is what you would see
of course where this arrow is is the new
within that Vista
and you'll notice how the elevation here
is broken by the planting in front of
the building
we have a longer shot from Great Eastern
Road you can see how Crown house already
made
presents felt
it actually takes up a lot of that
view from Great Eastern
Road and then we'll superimpose
in effect re-knitting reach restoring
the built form that used to be at that
end of of Sudbury Town Center behind
of course here is the new entrance to
the park and here is all the planting
and planting in the park and proposed
planting to go with the new entrance
an existing shot the rear of Bellevue
house and will superimpose the proposed
development
sitting in here
you'll notice from this Vantage Point
that's one of the least
parts of from where you would see that
development
and again I've just superimposed that
for just to remind members of the
relationship between the entrance and
the development so in terms of the
section 106 what is being provided is a
42
acute towards pedestrian Crossing
previously there is the standard
monitoring fee within the 106 for
monitoring the clauses
we're also suggesting that there's a
definite
trigger
links delivery of the park Improvement
works
to a phase program of construction for
the retirement living
we have also secured since the pre
-from the developer
they will be willing to restrict
occupations within the retirement living
scheme where you mind it to be
approve that
to a point at which
Bellevue house itself has to be fully
restored and converted and available for
occupation
so with this in place there will be no
Prospect
of seeing a retirement living scheme
completed and not seeing the
refurbishment
of Bellevue house
and that's the point that you'll
remember
Sudbury Society
urged us to make sure that we didn't let
the retention and conversion of Bellevue
I'll slip through our fingers and
somehow a develop
ment living component
we're suggesting a reasonable trigger
would be 15 occupations out of the
after that no more occupations unless
Bellevue house has been fully restored
converted and available for occupation
S2 dwellings
just want to raise some possible points
of reflection of the committee this
isn't an exhaustive list but it struck
me that the first thing to acknowledge
is that this scheme does provide for the
retention and refurbishment of Bellevue
house
it also ensures that the historic
relationship between Bellevue house and
the park is preserved
it has to be acknowledged that where you
might need to Grant permission there
would be a loss of some
trees those trees currently do make an
impact in terms of the character of this
part of the
Eastern end of
Sudbury but what we're trying to do here
with this development is restore the
former built townscape at the Eastern
end
of Sudbury Town Center where in fact
repairing the townscape at this end and
at the same time
we are encouraging the Regeneration of
the Eastern
Eastern North Center
so this site at the moment is is
in down
we have secured
extensive replacement planting that also
has to be acknowledged and the point I
made about
extra heavy standards could actually be
an important addition
it's also worth acknowledging that this
development if approved helps the
council deliver the multi-million pound
Park entrance
feature another element in the
Regeneration of the Eastern end of
Sudbury Town Center
it does allow us to tackle the derelict
nature of the existing site although it
has to be acknowledged
in terms of local objections
but the loss of this site is seen as the
loss of potential deliver to deliver new
recreational facilities
adjacent
as part of Bellevue Park
again it is stimulating new investment
in Sudbury
creating short-term construction jobs
longer term jobs in terms of staff and
indirect service jobs
just a reminder there you've got a shot
of
the back of Bellevue house as restored
top right
this building would look like
write an extract from your adopted local
plan
the basic layout
so on that basis offices are
recommending that subject to the prior
agreement of a section 106 as set out in
the report and explained earlier
providing that's to the satisfaction the
chief planning officer you give the
chief the jailing officer authority to
Grant full planning permission with
appropriate
Gemini I'm able to take questions
they arise thank you
thank you Vincent
any questions for the officer
cancer Lindsay please
sorry
um yeah thanks for that that was a long
presentation uh
uh some of it helpful
um but I don't know where the um
uh you talk about the mppf and paragraph
99
and that you're relying on B which is um
equivalent or better for because because
of the fact we're removing some open
space
you can argue about whether the pool's
open space or not but you acknowledge
that
a part of that site is open space By Any
even by baby council's definition
um so you have to justify it and your
justification is that you're providing
better provision
um in quantity and quality where's the
quantity
coming from
if accepting that the entrance is making
a better quality where is the quantity
the quantity arises from the fact that
the majority of the park entrance
improvements are across what is the
southern half of the old
so that is additional
land formerly additional land to the
park it becomes part of the park as a
result of being its entrance
yes of course sorry
let's
now I'm gonna have to laboriously
quickly track back oh I don't worry
there we go
so
what you wouldn't have known
debate we had at the previous committee
about the park entrance detail
which is an extensive area
Pierce
all of this is added
quantity but that's already sorry that's
already public space surely it's already
it doesn't it's not private space is it
the bit the bit to the which bit are you
saying is new is is extra public space
in quantity yeah all of that this isn't
that in the park already
okay thank you for clarifying that yeah
um and the other the other point I had
was um
the
a question really was um
uh over the
well really to question why you're you
seem to be relying on on um a lot on um
the fact that Bellevue house has
demolished the
the wing and improve and restore it and
so on but actually in the uh in par in
the actual um
paragraph 9.23 in our papers
it says we should not for any weight
on
the fact that they're refurbishing it
because actually
um you shouldn't put any weight on facts
being deliberately they've built an
extension on it that has been removed
shouldn't we shouldn't put any weight on
that at all
I'm not suggesting that you give the
retirement living
element of this proposal any extra
weight as a result of that extension
being demolished
what I am am saying is that this scheme
would deliver the refurbishment of
Bellevue house
in totality and it's that that's
important it's Bellevue house that makes
the important contribution
in terms of the character of the park
the relationship between the Victorian
house and the park and the quality of
the townscape hereabouts whilst it's not
a listed building it has been
acknowledged to be locally listed so it
has local value it is a an interesting
example of high Victorian architecture
and if we can we ought to do everything
we can to
retain it
now the point about the extension is
it's a bit of a bonus to secure the the
demolition of a later Edition to
actually restore Bellevue house back to
its original
um
form but I wouldn't in any way Advocate
that members allow the retirement living
scheme simply to secure the demolition
of that later extension that is not what
I'm I'm
at and I have one final question sure if
that's all right
um the the fact that we're not getting
any sale contribution or any affordable
houses from this development
um
I
we seem for that we're we're relying on
a recommendation
uh to the people compiling the jlp the
jlp as far as I'm aware that
recommendation hasn't been accepted
officially because the jlp isn't in
force
so
um we seem to be saying uh we shouldn't
rely on the jlp at all almost no weight
to it because it's not going to happen
but suddenly when a development we we
want to see because we want the answer
to presumably it comes a long way um we
want to put weight on a recommendation
not a not an actual Council decision but
a recommendation by a consultant
um that they shouldn't that that we
shouldn't get any affordable housing or
sell out
that's how do how can you can you
explain that
um
I think
Chief planning officer will answer your
question councilor Lindsay
thank you Jim
um yes so the recommendation sits within
the evidence base to the Joint local
plan which the council has accepted is
appropriate for the purposes of
preparing and producing and providing
its jlp to the inspector so the council
as a whole accepts the evidence base
underpinning the jlp it's for the
inspector to examine the jlp and to draw
a conclusion and as you see from the
report I think at paragraph 319 Etc we
draw a distinction between the evidence
base
for jlp and the jlp itself jlp needs to
be examined by the inspector the
evidence base is part of that but as far
as I'm aware nobody has challenged that
evidence base
and in Practical terms that leads us to
a conclusion that the development would
not be viable with um
affordable housing content
I have the future with the Chinese
Champion's place I
sorry Ken so Lindsay we we can't do that
at this meeting thank you
hello beer you were the next one thank
you Mr chairman
um well I've got three questions at the
moment but I'll try and be brief on them
just follow along from my colleague
behind I've got a question on that so I
fully support his views there it does
seem to me that
um you know I wonder where we would have
been done this sort of innovative would
have been private Enterprise Mr chairman
the council's involved in this and we're
not asking for any sale money or
affordable housing that doesn't seem to
stack up but anyway I'll move on to my
two questions because I'm going to come
back to that point in the debate uh is
that
um Vincent said that um the 106 with the
entrance uh is Paramount to all this has
that got to be built before the
um development
uh commences
um because as you know five members of
this planning committee didn't want it
and that only got through by one vote no
it's been mentioned many times that my
question is fellow
um that this entrance uh if it's going
to happen
um should happen before this development
because otherwise we could find the
development stand and uh the entrance
isn't so can you clarify that point
please and then I've got another
question
thank you councilor beer the third
bullet point in the recommendation
actually indicates that is to be agreed
within the 106.
So my answer to your question is at
present it isn't necessarily
acquired in advance of any work
starting
in respect of the
retirement living we
but that is something
that may come out of the debate and it's
something for the chief planning office
to reflect on
as a result of that debate
so what you're saying is that it is not
um necessarily going to happen
beforehand could we as the committee
insist that before any uh development to
a development of that site of these
residential houses and the Improvement
to Bellevue that the entrance
uh is put in first
is that possible yes or no because the
only button
the gift of the
gift of the Council group so I'll
perhaps leave Mr ears Bell to uh reflect
yeah reply yes before we get to Mr
Isabelle's reply because I I've got an
idea what that's going to be Mr chairman
that my point really is that should be
for this committee to make that decision
not left to uh with great respect to the
two plan Lobster to the planning office
or to an officer to agree this somewhere
down the line
that's what I'm afraid of
if I may come in chairman so paragraph
99b does not contain any time limits and
it's silent as to the the when it simply
says replace provided there is a program
for replacement which delivers that we
achieve the purpose of paragraph 99b in
the APF
back then to the program two points are
right it's it's for the committee is if
it wishes to choose a timetable it that
that's one option wishes to
hear some sort of review of that program
it could do that even
um
there is a I suppose from my perspective
the delivery of the park entrance
is something
that's in the control
um
So to that extent are we suggesting that
what
got me a question with a question
what you could foresee happen would be
that you then have a situation where the
delivery of the park entrance must be
started completed and concluded and then
you have a bill program for this
development so that in terms of timing
that elongates the process in which any
disturbance associated with delivery of
both schemes happens it delays the start
of work on delays the start of work on
restoration renovation of Bellevue I'm
not convinced that's to the good but it
is it is within your gift as a committee
to choose that timing we recommend
understanding the commercial nature of
development that there be a phased
program agreed because as planning
officers we don't have visibility over
the delivery of the entrance as it sits
within the asset arm of the council
But ultimately the point is then that
that program needs to deliver the
entrance at some timing so that by the
time
the part elements of this site are no
longer Park that there is that
replacement and that will be delivered
and that's what it is to secure so you
could do that you would potentially
elongate the process I'm not going to
speak about wrong boxes that's that's
true so you're actually saying we could
do it if the committee is so chose to
thank you
um because the other point you said uh
it's been going on for 25 30 years so a
few more years a delay isn't going to
make any difference no I'm sorry
that's an opinion rather than a question
uh
and drag it out longer which I accept
but we've already taken a long time my
other question was that yeshu quite a
few
pictures for instance of the front of
the um site the police station and and
going back to the 1960s I think it was
when it was demolished uh and you show
up as an area that was going to be
improved which really in those days that
was quite a wide open space it didn't
have concrete Islands as we have
nowadays didn't have lots of signs stuck
all over the place didn't have key left
quality this whole massen area is being
increased considerably and it will cause
tremendous traffic chaos onto the
coronard road in front of the question
please when my question was that I think
you've not shown that picture really
we've
you're trying to make it that this is
going to be such a great Improvement but
it was already an open area in the 60s
it wasn't like it is today and you're
going to add these buildings there on
the front which I think are unsightly
that's my question
well
the reason the lesson of the building on
the front panel
I'm not sure that what is a question
either sorry I'm not trying to be
awkward Council but that sounds to me is
that's your opinion
and it may or may not coincide with your
opinion my opinion okay I'll expect that
all right thank you thank you
McCrory
[Music]
I'd like to focus on the same area
actually uh though 1926 slide
um of police station block for slides 15
16-17 and the merger and I wanted to
contrast those and just if you could run
us through those briefly again
um to contrast the change in appearance
from
1926 the current state of play as it
were with the swimming pool for the
fence the graffiti uh that unsightly
mess the only word for it and the
proposed area I'm just trying to point
out and it's about the angle of
elevation because the police station was
further further west
um this is further back and then we have
this sort of upward Hill View and I just
wondered if you could take us through
the topography running from the Town
Center where the height of the former
police station would have been and and
then
where the height of the current wall
with that view that's just coming in
from the building crown
um house or something and then the
proposed elevations of the
um buildings behind which is the
retirement blocks and the Bellevue house
at the back
I know that's asking a broad thing but I
think it's actually quite a crucial
aspect of it and I just want to get it
clear in my head so that's the corner
so here is the corner with the police
station I actually think it gives me a
link to the question BYU Council Liberia
as as well
so as you can see the police station was
a
dominant three-story building with roof
sitting at the Eastern end of King
Street it was much closer
closer to the town center it sort of
lines up with the end of that existing
building so it actually had a very
dominant
impact in terms of the townscape it is
effectively at the foot of the current
slope
now what happened was in the 1960s when
it was demolished
a whole series of Highway improvements
to relieve traffic I assumed to relieve
traffic in the in the Sudbury itself in
terms of creating the a131 Ring Road and
that imposed a massive amount of change
on this end of the town in terms of the
highway geometry in the roundabout and
all those complicated Junctions
I think what it also did
because when you stand there today I I
would readily accept the point I think
you made councilor beer that there is a
plethora of signs
Street Furniture I would call it a lot
of visual clutter the fact that it isn't
an a road blasting through there has
enormous road signs that are very
dominant in the street scene
I believe I'm right in terms of
stating that Suffolk County Council is
already working on a separate piece of
work outside of this application and
outside of this immediate planning Arena
that
in a series of of Works to this part of
Sudbury in terms of Highway improvements
that could include
some decluttering of that and adjusting
a geometry but I'll leave that to my
colleague Ben to to comment on but
if we now picture this site with the
police station demolished
the wall that you see here is
effectively what was at the back of the
site of the police station
so I think I would have to argue that
the former police station
compared to what is now being proposed
was a more dominant element in the
street scene
we can't obviously restore the historic
townscape we can't repair the fabric in
terms of bringing a building forward
because it would be impossible because
the roadworks so what we've done what
we're recommending is that that
restoration
further eastwards so it will still make
a strong Presence at the East
[Music]
Center
but visually it will not be as prominent
as the police station
we have a look at slide 2930 which shows
the existing look
that's the bit 29. and there's the
entrance there's the entrance which is
sort of around the side it is around the
side and there's sort of a bit of a bit
of a sort of cloaker um it's a sort of
you have to go around some dark passage
it curves around in fact I would be a
little bit nervous about traveling down
there where I uh a single woman perhaps
at night or in the automobile's not open
at night but anyway certainly I went
down it and having had some difficulty
finding it and I I did reflect it didn't
look a comfortable place for some people
to be
it's around the corner from that wall is
that correct
so yeah
on this slide
further back up
[Music]
and in a way that potentially gives us
another connection to the point that you
made earlier
councilor beer about the triggers
between new entrants
and this development
obviously what we don't want to have is
a position whereby the existing Newton
Road Park entrance is closed and that
there is an alternative
available so somewhere in that thinking
we have to try and work out how we
organize that switch
so that there is always the second axis
because you'll remember Ingram's Well
Road has an access we must at all points
have this second access so that might
help in some of the debate later but the
answer to your question councilor core
is this would have a less
dominant
impact I would argue in terms of the
townscape compared to the old police
station and because of that slope and
because we've managed to drop the
nearest end of the building by a story
staggering and setting back when
actually prevent it from appearing
monolithic
and then finally could we just see the
last impact of the
um the end view as it were looking from
the West
towards the retirement block replacing
where the wall is now and the graffiti
they just wondered if we could contrast
and compare those
I just need to
I'm afraid we're gonna have to
sorry is that just a that's of course
the entrancy referred to difficult to
find and potentially on The Dark Night
not the most appealing of access but I
think it's applied 50. 50.
there we are
end on view of that so this might be
slide 51 which is the face on impact
yeah no it's not that one sorry about
that there is an end on view there we
are that's the one
comparing the heights of those with the
police station Heights was there any um
comparison
I think it was difficult because they
have different Victorian police station
may have had
um higher floor to ceiling Heights but
you see that the
police three stories
and we see that this element is three
stories here
up to that point
it may or may not be broadly equivalent
to the police station this actually is
four stories on this bit
but you'll notice
tempted not to try and go back
but what the police station shop you had
that
um
oyster-shaped Gable
which actually added to the apparent
height of the the building so whilst it
had a very strong vertical emphasis of
three stories and a steep slate roof it
also had that rather decorative oyster
Gable which actually added a
lot but a suggestion to help yeah it was
a flat wall wasn't it these things it
was a broad wall rather than a curved
movement that's all I'm just one is
[Music]
because it's
so there was a slide where you showed
roof lines yes
yes
thank you
there's always a danger if you
guesstimate
during a meeting somebody will say Mr
Pierce misled the committee by
guesstimating incorrectly
but but I would expect a Victorian
police station to have had higher floor
to ceiling Heights than the modern
building so
I'd rather not guesstimate because
I accept that could you could we could
you show us the the cross sections yeah
of course
I'm just gonna quickly
somehow jump us straight to
I've got it as slide
76.
but effectively 93
third slide
please
oh okay well I can I'm sorry yeah and
you did say I apologize counselors that
you did say
um we were asked a question I'll ask a
question
um
would it be fair to say the site of the
could you hover your thing where the
site of the police station was some
so that is lower ground
than where the retirement home is going
to be isn't it yes so you're talking
about a three-step story dwelling around
there
yeah so it
oops I don't know you don't want to say
where roughly where the height is but
that a factor to take into account that
if you're you know the number one
Heritage asset is the church grade one
listed
um
police station
is on Lower ground than the than the and
it may well not have been compared with
the you know the view from the church it
may well not have been as impactful as
this
as a retirement
thank you folks it's Angela Hinton
you've been very patient
nobility not going anywhere at the
moment
a couple of couple of questions firstly
page 36 it talks about environmental
health
sustainability walking
sustainability
protein there is nothing in the
sustainability list
sorry in the conditions list set to
reflect their sustainability condition
so that's one thing I think all to be
put in there
and if so what do they actually mean by
a sustainability condition
um
page 33 Anglin Moore to talk about their
surface water drainage should be by our
Sun's scheme there are various bits and
pieces on page
um
yeah page 65 where it talks about
improve approval of details for the
implementation maintenance and
management of the approved strategy for
the disposal of surface water prior to
the commencement development well that
strategy could mean we're going to shove
it all down to the sewers it doesn't say
that it's going to be a sud scheme
submission for approval of of surface
water drainage verification report
within 28 days of practically practical
completion of the last dwelling or unit
well that's a bit like sort of closing
the horses the stable door after the
halt is not only bolted but gone around
the circuit and come back again probably
um
approval of a construction service Water
Management none of those relate to a sun
scheme you mentioned a couple of blue
blobs on one of the drawings but that
doesn't mentioned anywhere within our
report
so are we supposed to say that those
diagrams that you've been producing are
the essential part of the planning
approval if so why would we can copies
of them so that we could approve them or
not
uh would be uh on the on this parking
issue uh it talks about
occupancy restricted to people over the
age of 55.
that in theory gives people a 10-year
working life before they retire at the
compulsive of the current retirement age
although I think he's gone up from there
now isn't it sixth year where it's going
up all the time isn't it
um so there's going to be more and more
than moving around and driving around
perhaps it also talks about the the
criteria where they came up with this
figure of what was it 12 point something
or other or 0.28 or something per flat
where the people were 79
well there's a hell of a difference
between 55 and 79
all the rest of it and it talks about
potential employment prospects
from the development after it's
completed and everybody's in there in
terms of presumably running the cafe
that's in there and various things like
that well that will require staff
parking Etc so everything adds up to the
fact that there's going to be an awful
lot more cars in there than 0.28 per per
apartment and there is not sufficient
parking being put in there I'm sorry
just to put one last point in there
we've had a bit about Suds and how the
suds rates are being changed
um without approval by Council
and the evidence base changing for the
for the new joint local plan well the
evidence based as far as I can figure
out it's changing virtually daily that's
one of the things that the planning
inspector has been commenting on and
saying I'm not going to put a timetable
on it because it keeps changing all the
time so the evidence base is changing
but without the council being notified
as to what
changes are or approving those changes
and yet it says at the bottom of page
five
9.22 the development would also generate
a return in terms of sell receipts at
the present time which is of itself an
economic benefit although albeit of
limited weight so they're talking about
still there now if that's still just for
Bellevue house
why is it not still on the
the apartments uh development there
because that's going to generate an
awful lot more revenue for somebody
I've made a note councilor Hinton I
would accept absolutely your first point
that um
we should add a sustainability
condition but I notice my eye has been
caught by the chief planning officer
I hesitate to correct You Vince Midway
down page 64 you'll see a condition
which is marked approval of a scheme
the provision and implementation of
water energy and resource efficiency
measures which I'm afraid is a bit of a
mouthful but his hair officers in
practice write sustainability conditions
into these permissions unless
pretty much our model template for as
you'll see construction operational
phases of the development so
uh middle middle bullet of page 64.
about the ninth bullet down approval of
a scheme for the provision and
implementation of water energy and
resource efficiency measures during
construction and operational phases it
might have been simpler for officers to
say sustainability I agree
grateful to the chief planning officer
for uh
highlighting that
so and turning to your question about
sustainability of drainage uh may I
refer you to the final bullet on page 64
and the bullets on page 65 at the top of
page which relate to disposal of surface
water strategy for that to be agreed on
page 64 and then a strategy for the
implementation maintenance management of
the approved strategy for the disposal
of surface World propriety commencement
so that's the effectively the management
and maintenance of that strategy once
it's been agreed and then following on a
surface water drainage verification
report and a construction surface water
management plan to prior to commencement
so those three bullets on page 64 and
page 60
five
final bullet on page 64. I think should
pick up the uh surface water drainage
the sustainable drainage issues in uh in
terms of conditions chairman the Mr
chairman is the the chief planning
officer has just mentioned one word
they're sustainable drainage but angling
water are talking about a sud scheme
which is a sustainable Urban drainage
scheme nowhere is that mentioned
anywhere and all that verbiage that is
in those three three or four bullet
points
cancel cancelings and I do apologize
that we didn't use the word a
sustainable Urban drainage system but in
essence that is what those conditions
address
can I just add councilor Hinton that
County Council is the Suds Authority and
the floods Authority
have looked at a wealth of background
detail that I haven't shown you today
because
when I tried to do in the presentation
was simply highlight
how the attenuation
underground attenuation tanks would be
would be catered the fact that the
drainage from this development runs into
them first and then discharges
at the system
floods Authority and suds Authority is
satisfied with the wealth of detail that
we've already had as the chief planning
officer as pointed out to us the extra
conditions are those required by
the
destruction
Environmental management plan and that's
to ensure that during construction and
in contaminants that arise on site from
the construction process do not end up
in the Watercourse that's why that one's
been
out
separately
so in terms of drainage the relevant
drainage Authority is satisfied with the
arrangements and we have the backup of
the conditions to ensure that the detail
we've seen is what is implemented and
the County Council has
has a site oversight over that
in terms of sustainability all members
will have a chance to I'm assuming that
the applicant is making a rep utation
in which case you will be able to ask
them directly as to the likely
credentials
of their scheme in terms of what sort of
energy will they be using whether it be
PV and that is something that would come
out in in those sustainability reports
that we've conditioned but it does give
you an opportunity Grill them
to face to try and understand where
they're coming from
I would also perhaps
I've already said that I'll leave some
time for my colleague Ben to talk about
the Highway aspects of this
of this but it has to be said that in
terms of our
settlement hierarchy Sudbury sits at the
very top of that as a town in Sudbury it
is the most sustainable location
we have and as such that also is
something that I imagine my colleagues
at summer County Council will also take
into account when thinking about the
parking and traffic implications of the
scheme
a moment
where Ben you would want to
answer that specific question raised by
councilor Hinton
yeah well um point out that the
proposed parking here is actually 0.4
per unit
um as as opposed to to
0.28 that was shown on the on
a slide um
I think
0.28 was the
yeah average from the the
Churchill
um
surveyed sites
so the proposal here is it is a higher
than the average from from the other
Churchill sites that were that
were surveyed um
and we've regard to to impact
traffic we we have to
take into account the um the
permitted use which is for 460 square
meters of office space a
bed a lview house so that um so the the
all-cast movements from from this prop
proposal are actually less than the the
um committed usage
thank you
thank you
Council Busby you have a question
no I can't I can't point you to uh
policies that says we will try and
restore
historic fabric of the Town Center but
as a plan
dealt with heritage that is an Urban
Design
movies it is something that you would
ordinarily expect to do in an historic
town center
would aim to improve
improve or not try and recreate the
mistakes of the past
and at that point chair we have
discussion as to whether
councilor Busby's opinion that it's a
mistake or my opinion that it's actually
restoring historic fabric
takes us from questions into debate
I think you're right
and I don't agree with either of you but
that's going for the debate sorry the
question was valid where where has the
restoration of the historic townscape
come
I don't I've never been aware of that's
one of the objectives of this this
particular application or any other
application
and then I did give an answer I can't
point you to a policy
because it's good conservation
approach
this is on the edge of an adjacent to a
Conservation Area
restoring historic fabric is is
generally seen as a good thing
thank you councilman I know you might
disagree with the answer but you have an
answer councilor McLaren you were next
sure
events
um I just want to clarify about a
conflict of
um two sentences within the report which
was uh that Sudbury does not have a
neighborhood plan but the one of the
objectives I think said it was
conflicting with the neighborhood plan
um the Subway have a oh just somebody
not have a neighborhood plan
but but one of the objectives actually
said it was in conflict with the
neighborhood plan
whether they're misquoting a different
sort of plan but as a statement of fact
it is incorrect well I don't know
whether a Sudbury had one or many
a bit bigger than the neighborhood
plants I'm familiar with
um I have some concerns about this
parking spaces
my colleagues have raised
Jones
that are different to mine and the
question is about
the assessment of the type of resident
that is going to
uh
okay be in this accommodation
um
we've talked about younger residents but
we're in an aging population
and my question is that if this is not a
care home
I don't think it's supported living it's
supported living but somebody can
correct me on that which means all these
people
could require Care at a later date
that's 43 residents who will be
receiving care there's no mention of
staff parking
there's no mention of visit to parking
and so the question is
do you think the parking spaces are
enough but what is going to
in the in the light of the new
integrated care system or the Health
Service which is about
um
giving and providing Services outside of
main centers of care then the future for
this
um
development
means that I think means that parking is
inadequate and can we actually can you
um review that or can we review it
as officers on the advice of our
colleagues at Essex County we are saying
that this is adequate based on
what our colleagues at County understand
to be the way that these Churchill
retirement living schemes operate it
might be something that you want to ask
directly of the applicant when you have
a chance to say how are they so
confident that this
I know of a lot of these schemes across
Suffolk and Essex where they do operate
at these levels and appear not to be
causing
any difficulty
that you might want to consider and I'm
just
seems dangerous and it's something that
the applicants haven't had a chance to
consider
it might be possible to provide a pool
car on this site so that residents
wouldn't miss
they would have access to a car that
might be another way of of increasing
the sustainable credentials of this
scheme because we're already asking for
100 electric vehicle charge
it might be something you want to
consider as a as a way of trying to
tackle your concern about future parking
pressure issues if actually residents
have access to a vehicle and we've seen
on other schemes people like
provide those I just I just raise that
in
as an answer to the question that may or
may not be taken up in debate
thank you
Council rowing you had a question yes
thank you chair
um
the waist
um there was an issue with the bins
um have they been sorted out yet
on the 20th of May 22 22 the Western
environment response
I was just wondering whether they'd been
sorted out
we are satisfied that bins are
adequately accommodated
can have you got a slide that I can see
I haven't got that actually within the
presentation
although I I suggested it was
comprehensive it's not comprehensive
enough to include that
whether or not in
we can find that
fun
we are we are
absolutely sure that the refuse
freighter can get in and out of the
so
All Points would be within the
appropriate distance to a refuse
freighter to get the waste away
Thank You Vince can I just um I just
want to um
ask ask you to say sentence again on Sly
day please
[Music]
I
through
[Music]
another 17.
I'll just say on there it says 17.
I would say oh sorry
yeah yeah I think that's the one
um I can't even see that see it now on
yeah that'll be great on B
you've you put on there can you read
that out again for us please no is it
no on C sorry to apologize
I've got the wrong side
I've got the wrong slide bin
there was something you said and and you
said in it you said or not and and it
was all about the open space
is it
all right okay sorry it's on a then
foreign
[Music]
we have
an earphone
options
foreign
yeah no I've just seen where I've
see it now when you said it before you
said or better provision in terms of
quantity or quality I was just
correcting you on what you think I
couldn't see it because it wasn't
and quality that's what I wanted to
correct you on I do apologize
thank you everything else has been
answered I think any more questions for
the officer
um is
the start of putting all our planning
policies to one side to get an
application across the line
I don't think it's a question
you can expect the opposite to answer
because if you want I mean calcium cruel
saying it's not fair let me just run
through it shall we no affordable
housing no 106 contribution apart from
42 000 which represents 1 000 per unit
no seal no parking up to standard
um no I'm just clarifying your concern
um also um
I sit here on many occasions when we
have listed buildings nearer
or further away from the site
and we are always given less than
substantial harm
we have a grade one listed church we
have numerous grade two properties
and there's not a mention of um less
than substantial harm so I'm just
wondering where
at what point have we decided that our
policies are being put to one side and
actually we put this through is it
possibly because we own the land I mean
far beer for me but if I was a developer
looking at this application I'd go
whoopee babe we've got policy changes
coming along be a lot easier to get my
applications through now
I think we'll ask the chief planning
officer to attempt to answer your
question
to attempt to take that in no particular
order the question of less than
substantial you'll have there's advice
and there's a judgment for you to make
this advice in your papers which we say
there is not an issue to you know we've
got the advice is set out in the papers
in full to
clarify that position as regards the
application of
assessments and policies no we're not
departing from the plan except where we
consider that's expedient we've dealt
with the weight to be attached to the
plan within the report and that
effectively you have to weigh out the
tying of the core strategy the saved
local plan policies and the nppf and the
nppf trumps all because that looks for
policies to align with it so that is the
thing that in you in in the question of
up to date in this you must always turn
to for certainty
um and you're doing that with every
policy all the time
um and you know clearly the uh
the question of whether the council is
pursuing the application it's been dealt
with as any other application and in
fact probably there has been more
attention to
the objectivity of this report than you
would find in some other development
application reports for developments by
others because we are perfectly aware as
officers that the scrutiny of this is a
matter of
Pub that it has been looked at very
carefully with all the exceptions
um we will have to just judge it and
weigh those balances up which is what
we're here for
anymore of course it counts of beer
what no hang on that I all need to be to
the opposite these are questions for the
officer
thank you
all right
um it's instant slide 75 uh if you can
find that
um which shows the picture of the
heights
um the pub that's in the picture I think
it's the Royal Oak is that the one at
the bottom yeah whatsoever the plow the
bear bear right uh there the the police
station
is lower down because it's on the
flatter land if you look at slide 75
you will find I'd like to know how much
higher
the the new buildings are because
they're three-story if you put them
against that Public House
that's considerably higher
sorry 70 75th
um yeah no
if you the police station would have
come down further and be more on the
flatter so and the police station was
three-story
the pub there if you line that up to the
police station that would be about
halfway I reckon up that building
so that's misleading that's what I'm
trying to say no
you live somewhere there so that's
considerably higher I think I would have
to disagree because if you took it
halfway up this building that would take
it to the roof line of
we'll go a little bit higher then but
you can see my paint that is concerned
if we go up another story
say to there
the three stories of the police station
approximately bearing in mind that this
is still only a guesstimate and took the
line across
this building is higher but of course
the police station also had a heard of
Truth
think about where a pitch through fight
be we might get to that point but so yes
it is higher that new building is
already on raised Grace the police
station was on Lower ground bm3 story
compared to the pub that is considerably
higher that was my point there anyway
we'll move on and my question Mr
chairman to the
um highways officer is you're really
trying to tell us that 16 parking spaces
is adequate there for people who are 55
plus perhaps a couple who are still in
work
um perhaps
um got jobs where they need a vehicle
you're seriously telling us that this is
sufficient I mean come on that just
cannot be right you've got 44 dwellings
there they're not all going to be
occupied by 79 year olds and I know some
79 year olds who are quite capable of
driving and using vehicles
um
what's up I'm sorry uh ignore that bit
um I I just can't see how you can sit
there and say that this is acceptable
you obviously don't know hang on we've
still had problems with parking in
Sudbury the roads there and you're
saying that this will not generate more
chaos
you need parking spaces
well
how
outstanding is the
is the ridge age of the
the much higher than
55 so that would uh
how okay or of course no guarantee but
we have
accepted this based on the the
surveys from Churchill who who
who've okay Karen out surveys at aimless
sites and
um
Justified that it was
you know it's provisional
for this this
type of of sight and um in the past
where where we have a opportunity
XM
phrase phrase of residential homes and
upheld it it um it has gone gone to a
handing appear elsewhere and we haven't
been enabled
you uphold our
auction out planning appeal
thank you
thanks for having me can we I'll be
asking questions to the highways now is
it cushions the highways now are we
allowed to
any questions to the officers but if you
want to
feel like
yeah okay well then
yeah if you have to carry on
thank you
right
um
six
right can I read a statement out from
the Suffolk highways first please
um it's in your response date the 22nd
of December 2021 it states
the proposed parking provision does not
occur occur with Suffolk guidance for
parking 2019 however given the evidence
of parking demand provides some subjects
to the above contribution to reduce
Reliance on motor vehicles and travel
and and local parking restrictions
around the development we are satisfied
that A reduced Precision provision is
Acceptance in this instance
so I've got a couple of questions on
this how does the contribution to a
Crossing reduce cars that's my first one
the second one is where are the parking
restrictions around Newton Road
um because there's no dub there's a
little bit of wlins for this people can
park up there
and my third question is
why has highways accepted the transport
statement about the number of trips as
Bellevue house has not been used for
years
okay yeah thank you
if I was highlighting the the
just just to note that this this
contribution will will be to Awards
pedestrian Crossings
improvements that
the
orange
to access
local amenities
and arriving to them
um secondly about the
parking restrictions
um
we we are aware that
a part of the part of Newton Road
doesn't have any parking restrictions
but but the the key areas close coasters
to functions and interchanges to who
have
who have who have Park parking
restrictions so and the
the um if
we were to to object on on Park on on
parking it it has to be linked
to
parking
causing an impact
the highway so if there are if there was
some on on Street
parking near functions and crossings Etc
it's it's not
it's not enough for us to to uphold
enough
the
the areas of the hot the high way up
properly attacked by those parking
restrictions
um what was the other question sorry
why has highways accepted the transport
statement about the number of trips as
Bellevue house has not been used for
years I would say people open and
shutting the gates of of the park that
is all we get
thank you um yeah it's it's because it
has a
permitted
to you so we regardless of how long it
it hasn't been we we still have to take
into account
yeah
well please
a High Street full of empty shops but
you would assume that those shops might
be occupied hopefully when the economy
improved and that was so you take into
account the permitted use that's the key
if I've understood correctly that's the
quantity
committed use it's just happened
some time as you rightly say
a long long time can I just go back you
you said sorry about this Steve about
the contribution where reduced cars
because you said about on Foot Right can
I ask about the safety on foot then
um on how they get across the road then
um
because obviously if you're saying
you're thinking that they're all going
to walk into town and things like that
the safety of the of the people crossing
over the road from Newton Road if they
go that way
you've got two lots of Crossing but if
they don't go that way and they end up
going the cornered roadway
you end up going right the way around
the park
apartment yeah you know where I am and
then you've got the crossing what you
say You're Gonna
to do so then they've got a crossover
back road then then right if they're not
going to rise then they've got to cross
over
into a little middle bit so then they've
got a cross over there and then they've
got to wait for the all the traffic and
then they've got a nail and don't forget
there's a 78 year old people they've got
to then cross over to the next Road and
then they've still got to get to the
town
um
so I'm just wondering where everyone's
standing
[Music]
combined with with the ossing that that
will be provided by by The Arc entrance
app
application on on top of this how
to proposals they're not detailed as yet
or drawn up but the County Council us
have proposals to improve the
awesome
42 000 pounds that we 've asked for
would pay to Awards the the
SE improvements off the
Junction area
all right okay quick one then so you're
saying you're gonna the middle bit
you're gonna make good or you're just
saying you're just gonna do the crossing
I was just a bit getting confused about
the question I'm sorry I I I I
understand from colleagues that the
options are to create a link across the
island section so that the central part
or to or and or to
Road at the
end of
that
point of clarification it's in the
office of referring to the improvements
that Suffolk County Council highways are
going to do as a result of the
children's wood development and that may
be a long way off
certainly been part of this
[Music]
the Chilton woods but um
I I I'm not personally involved in these
schemes so I I can't
provide any specific details on the
funding sources or
details of these schemes but the the the
contribution has has been sought in
consultation with with our and sports
strategy sorry who are working on these
the
things so just to be clear the 42 000 is
planned for the Crossland and for an
improvement to the island in Great
Eastern Road because that's what you're
saying it's
towards it
sorry does it help
um Council agency you ask for a plan we
finally got it up so just to remind
members
it's part of the park entrance and the
one that councilor Owen referred to we
get a crossing at this point
at the moment there's a drop curb in
here which gets you to the central
island
there are dropped curbs at that point
which get you across that Island from
Girling Street and of course you can
cross there
cross-up points in here so I think what
Ben is saying that this area is going to
be look
and of course that's not part of this
proposal that's something those of you
that wear County hats presumably will
have an opportunity to
either support that proposal or ask
questions around it that sits outside of
this
planning Arena obviously people are
crossing here all the time at the moment
and I think what the county is saying it
might be time to look again
Crossing points in order to enhance
pedestrian safety
what we're saying is this delivers 42
000 pounds towards those works whatever
they may be and the park entrance
delivers
the
the controlled Crossing
point
so to be clear it's just the crossing
the 42 000 Dawn there's no guarantee of
the others were expecting County to look
at the others but but that isn't on the
radar so we should disregard that
Council record everyone just point to
clarification on that according to the
recommendation the 42 000 this is the
first point of the record
the contribution of 42 000 is to be used
towards improvements to The Pedestrian
Crossing facilities in the immediate
vicinity of the development to make the
development acceptable in this regard I
would take that to be the crossing
associated with the entrance application
that we already dealt with anything else
is going to be a separate matter for the
County Council and other authorities to
deal with
no
unless I've misunderstood
it's worth clarifying 42 000 is for the
crossing that's already been done
the park
comes with its own commitment to provide
a Crossing on cornard road that's not
what the recommendation says Vincent I'm
afraid it says towards The Pedestrian
Crossing facilities in the immediate
vicinity of the development that sort of
implies it is but of course here we are
the development is this
okay so the two are separate they are
separate so what is happening is not
clear from the recommendation then I
apologize that could have been worded
uh more precisely but what I can say is
the 42 000 would go to other works out
with the Crossing in cornight Road
that's already secured by the entrance
scheme
so that that's given that that's you
know the the County Council of asking
for that money for some improvements but
can I just check again what is the
status of this
it seems very very vague at this stage
um improving I mean because that
that roundabout is a mess it needs
improving
but did you say the budget hasn't been
um found the money hasn't been found for
that I mean it would cost Millions to
improve that Junction
um I this this will relates to The
Pedestrian Crossings of this this air
air it's not the whole that I a whole
remodeling of it it's um it's to
to improve the
opportunities for
to cross so I don't have any
specific details of these these
proposals business early on in the
design is there a chance it may never
happen
I don't think that's a fair question
yeah
yeah
yes
can we bring this up in the debate if
you've discuss it further if you feel
that story
um
from a point of clarification I'm not
promoting The Proposal they
we had an hour that sounded like you
were I made I'm not promoting The
Proposal that is something that my
colleagues an assistant I'm I'm
putting my recommendation as a
professional planning officer to you but
it is fair to say that this officers we
are satisfied
that this scheme works
whether or not
the County Council does a wider scheme
of
foreign
so I'm going to say right no more
questions for the officer at this stage
but he will remain available
if we want to question him during the
debate I'm also now going to suggest we
take a five minute Comfort break because
some of us have been sitting in these
chairs for over two and two and a half
hours so I think we deserve it a visit
to the little boy's room please can I
warn you not to discuss this matter with
anyone while you're away from this room
thank you
please take our seats
okay
welcome back
hope you're suitably refreshed we will
now move on to the public speaker side
of this planning application I will now
invite the Town Council representative
Ellen Murphy to address the committee
and you have three minutes to address
the committee
thank you chair
Sudbury Town Council which represents
approximately 14 000 residents has
opposed the development from the
beginning primarily because Bellevue
Park is a major asset for Sudbury which
could be enhanced opened up to Encompass
the town and the proposed regeneration
of Hamilton Road quarter
the evaluations in the paper talk of
public benefit but wouldn't a park open
to the general public be more of a
public benefit than creating residential
homes for a handful of people
there has been no clear explanation as
to why this isn't open space when it has
been recreational space and has never
been a Brownfield space the amount of
open space has been declining with all
the new housing developments and with
much more to come
it's a very old trees give us oxygen
store carbon stabilized soil but their
retention would be dependent on the
developer numerous trees will are being
lost due to development and climate
change old trees cannot be replaced it
doesn't matter you can't say you can't
replace a poultry if Bellevue house is
retained it will be hidden behind the
development access will be through the
retirement home car park
um and where there will be limited
private space any Bellevue house
developer would have the same issue
the planning committee visited the site
and the junction highways may say that
they are happy with this but this is one
of the busiest Junctions and traffic
will be going to and fro near to a busy
roundabout but they are again building a
block of Flats on a busy Junction is not
conducive to Peaceful healthy retirement
what is the detailed evidence that there
is a need for 41 or however many private
residential homes on the site and why on
this site rather than other available
sites around Sudbury we're not aware of
any detailed work carried out within
Sudbury rather than it then Elsewhere on
the need for this development Churchill
reports that there would be a 500 000
pounds of benefit but who exactly will
benefit certainly not residents of our
town we will lose valuable space which
could and should be used for the benefit
of residents and of course no seal
it concerns me that the views of the
Sudbury Society with limited membership
appear to carry more weight than that of
Sudbury Town Council or Bellevue Action
Group
if this application goes ahead we will
lose a valuable opportunity to enhance
the town with an amenity for all not
just a few please please when you vote
consider what is best for sudbury's
residents visitors and more importantly
generations to come ask yourselves
seriously how would I vote if Sudbury
was my hometown like it's mine and
finally in the words of JK Rowling
it is our choices that show who we truly
are far more than our abilities thank
you for listening to me
thank you
questions for the Town Council
representative
Council beer
um you stated quite a few
participants that you've spoken to and
what have you but
um you are aware that there was one
thousand eight hundred no 1085
um
signatures or online people that were
involved this is a considerable amount
of people from your area would you say
yes I can add that I especially over the
last 11 days but ever since I've been
mayor and certainly since I've been a
town councilor which is um three three
years I have spoken to people
continuously in the town I am in town
every single day and I'm a chatterbox so
I do talk to people and all the views
are that it would be such a shame if we
lost that what could be a beautiful
entrance and people cannot see the need
for this new development and also
there's comment about there's no social
housing involved
um is it that Bellevue house when it's
divided into two is going to be
affordable housing well I don't think so
thank you thank you
any more questions
nope thank you very much
um I understand
we have
an objector that's Laura Knight
thank you Laura you have three minutes
to address
the committee
the Bellevue Action Group has over 700
members and in a three-week period
during covert restrictions we obtained
nearly 1100 petition names and
signatures against this application
163 comments were received on baber's
planning portal for this application
with 159 objections and only two in
support Sudbury Town Council opposed
this development and Churchill's own
consultation generated a response of 87
opposed to its plans it's very clear
that Sudbury does not welcome this
development
Churchill has not provided local
evidence for this type of housing in
Sudbury these are over 55's private
flats for sale at Churchill's projected
cost of 300 000 for a 785 square foot
two bed flat plus management fees and
what we need in Sudbury is affordable
housing and social housing
despite holding objection by baber's
strategic housing department Churchill
intends to pay absolutely nothing
towards affordable housing and yet
Churchill was published in an estimated
2.4 million profit on this site which is
over 25 profit
the planning officer has yet again
stated that the swimming pool site is
previously developed land when it's
public open space and always has had a
recreational purpose and never been
developed on furthermore the planning
officer is requesting that committee
members must link this application to
the entrance application which has not
yet been right to permission and in
order to get around the mppf open space
requirements are power 99. the
fundamental basis of planning is that
each application must only be considered
on its own memories and not linked to
another applicant's application to try
and get around an issue
the mppf clearly states that any
existing open space should not be built
on unless it's Surplus to requirements
and Sudbury has been assessed by baber
as having a significant deficit of
Parkland has the worst Parish deficit in
the whole of Baylor and mid-suffolk
on the basis of this application loan
Sudbury is losing 336 square meters of
open space and land is asset of
community value and this is in direct
contravention of both the planning
policy cno3 and the nppf these
overbearing four-story Flats will both
block the historic key view of Saint
Peters and the tree canopy Skyline from
the park and instead the view from the
park will be a multi-story block of
flats the historic views of the house
and tree canopy cover that connect the
park from the Town Center's Conservation
Area will be lost and this is not
acceptable in Sudbury
proposed section 106 does not guarantee
the survival of Bellevue house and the
house renovation must be carried out
prior to the flats being built before it
deteriorates further additionally we
have concerns over having up to 15
elderly occupants in apartments on a
working building site there are also
serious concerns raising Rays regarding
them following the traffic impact which
has not been properly considered by
highways and RV the removal of access to
the park as part of this application and
last but not least a lot of historic
trees including a 300 year old you tree
at the house just to make way for a
single story extension for all these
grounds and there are more we would urge
the committee to recommend the
application for refusal
thank you I'd like to sit there we'll
see if there's any questions for you
any questions
cancel McLaren thank you chair my name
Laura
um
I'm not local to Sudbury
but I've listened to all these
objections by you and others and read
the objections
so
can you tell me what you would put in
its place if this development didn't go
ahead what what would you as as
residents of Sudbury want for Bellevue
house
and for all the so I do know the park so
uh it's not all green yeah and pleasant
is it so
what would be your suggestion for it
in my view and I live on a meeting Road
my house back's onto the park so I am
quite keenly interested in this the side
of the Bellevue Action Group
um but I would want to see the house
um sold and those proceeds are used to
open up the front of this park with a
swimming pool site
and I appreciate there are phased
approaches that need to be done but it
could definitely you could have genuine
quick impact Park improvements which is
what somebody's asking for they want
Park improvements not necessarily
extra concrete entrance so for me
using the house sale money to walk like
you know and having that renovated and
kept
um but then used for opening up the
front of this actually people can access
Bellevue
um you can see it around on that corner
and who would pay for all that well in
terms of it's a council the land is the
house itself is Council property
um so the funds from that and it's
public realm land
and given that the council are committed
already they've put in their budget 2
million for this plan for these entrance
on the other side and quite happy to
spend the money on that
um I don't think it's unreasonable to
ask for the house sale funds to be used
to support opening up the front and
whether it can be done in stages so you
can have some quite quick wins and
there's some Park improvements over time
which is exactly actually what the
council's already proposing doing on the
other side
thank you thank you chair thank you
kind of beer thank you good morning no
afternoon no
um
very far
um I think you were saying that um
there was you weren't happy with the
entrance
um
and
uh your concern was where that was going
to be and
um also that that doesn't open up at the
front
you commented about that and baber's
view on it
being
interesting entrance to them you said
something that the entrance was to the
solid which you didn't agree with
and
that
the
um in your little speech uh that the
front the front should be more made
available yeah okay can you just
elaborate on that form yeah I mean
obviously these are the cost issue so
for me and in my view I'm I'm quite
prepared to accept that you know that
the house would need to be sold to fund
something like that but in terms of
opening up the front we had a real
opportunity here to increase our open
space for Sudbury we've got more and
more housing coming
um and we should be doing more to sort
of have free
um access to park space by opening up
that front and and you've obviously got
the planning app already being agreed on
one side but actually extending that
across if you had something that went
across and opened up the other side
um for me that's where I think that um
you would get bigger benefits and it
would impact more people and Parks free
thank you thank you
any more questions
thank you very much
moving on we'll move on to
a supporter we have Mr Jack going and
you have three minutes to address the
committee
[Music]
okay thank you thank you very much
indeed chair for giving me the
opportunity to speak to the planning
committee
yes
no not a supporter of the scheme
they're not supporting these kids
they said you were speaking as a
supporter of the application of the
application
I'm afraid you're not afraid you're not
allowed to speak them
sorry
thank you very much
right
as we have no more supporters
I would now ask the agent
sorry
yeah but you're not into the agenda yet
sorry it's
she's his award member yes
you come after the county and the
counter then you're as the ward member
thank you
so we have
Lisa Matheson
yes you're there sorry thank you very
much I couldn't see you back
no problem you had three minutes to
address the committee okay thank you
chair members of the committee the
applicant has sought throughout the
application to work with your officers
and consultees as part of the proposals
and to enable and to assist in the
council's vision for the Regeneration
you haven't got the timer on
of this part of Sudbury and the
improvements to the park and we are
pleased with this recommendation for
approval the government identifies the
delivery of all the persons housing as
critical and the proposed development
offers a high quality scheme which has
evolved considerably through the input
of your offices for all the people on
this site there is a local need for
specialist accommodation the Strategic
housing market assessment from 2017
identifies there as an additional
requirement for some 2 579 units of
specialist older persons accommodation
by 2036 in this house and market area
the national planning practice guidance
advises authorities to take a positive
approach to schemes such as this where
there is an unmet demand
indeed from the 2021 census data
which was just released in June 2022 and
babe at the population size has
increased by some 5.2 percent there has
been an increase of 30.1 percent and
people aged 65 and over
in this time period
the applicant has positively sponsored
to comments from officers in the Sudbury
society and has amended the scheme to
reduce the scale and massing as you've
seen earlier in your offices
presentation
The Proposal will also ensure the
restoration and future reuse of Bellevue
house which is a locally listed building
much of the Parkland area contained
within the site will be maintained as
Landscaping going forward and the now
approved proposed amendments and
improvements to the park access and
Facilities more than offsets this public
space the landscaping and quality of the
Garden area within the proposed
development is very important and the
company has indeed won awards for such
schemes
the typical purchaser of the retirement
development is a 79 year old Widow often
move and follow in a significant life
event
it is typically a needs-based move with
their existing property no longer
suitable and it also becomes part of the
housing chain further down
the nature of residents together with a
sustainable location such as this
application site also reflects in a
lower level of car ownership and use the
proposed level of car Parker reflects
survey evidence of retirement
accommodation and existing schemes
nearby this is supported by your
highways Authority
the proposed design has had sustainable
construction methods as its heart
including measures to limit energy
consumption and CO2 emissions the
introduction of renewable energy through
solar PVS and the provision of electric
charging points for all proposed parking
spaces the scheme will deliver economic
benefits with the provision of direct
and indirect jobs will be an increase in
local spending on the high streets
there are significant social benefits
for the new community providing
residents with a social and friendly
environment these reduce the risk of
loneliness and social isolation
the proposals will provide an
opportunity for residents to downsize
free and up larger often unoccupied
family homes elsewhere in the housing
market I'm gonna stop you there you've
had a good three thank you thank
you sit time we'll see if there's any
questions for you yes certainly any
questions for the area
the councilman advised for you and
[Applause]
housing
area but the Shema relates to Ipswich
and its surrounding areas is that as
close that you've done you've not done
one specifically that housing market
assessment was in terms of the Census
Data provided that was linked to baber
and isolation itself
not just Sudbury itself no
if you don't mind roughly what kind of
price range will the the one and two
bedroom apartments flat speed the prices
haven't been set yet that's normally
something which has done stopped during
the construction period so okay but it
is obviously it's set um to be priced
for for people in the area
um of Sudbury itself
this scheme's not providing any
affordable housing that's contribution
uh one of the reasons that the Beijing
stoke
application went through was because the
inspector was impressed by the high
level
of substantial contribution to
affordable affordable housing how come
they can yeah affordable housing and we
can't yeah obviously each application is
determined on its own Merit you know
every site has got different viability
considerations obviously in this Council
area and we have the council's own
viability assessment which was described
beforehand by your officers provides you
know thorough evidence that in this
Council
um area that schemes a specialist
accommodations such as this before you
cannot afford to pay any um affordable
housing contributions and also within
Sil um in the council's OR charging
schedule
um specialist accommodation is exempt so
no houses and for special accommodation
throughout the authority we provide
um Sil um or a provision of this use
okay I can't believe that Beijing Stoke
is a cheaper place to provide this kind
of units than than Sudbury but obviously
we've slipped up there by putting that
kind of restriction in our own plans
so thank you McLaren you had a question
thank you chair my name is Matheson
well I I raised earlier about the
parking
um can I just clarify the
the the sort of name of the or the type
of accommodation is retirement living
can I just
explore that a bit before I ask you the
question what does that actually entail
for the resident
the least requires that somebody the
main applicants moving in has to be 60
years of age or over they can have a
spouse and a partner that is 55 years of
age I know that the um the officer has
got a condition attached which says over
55 but it is required that one or the
main occupants is over 60 years of age
so if that would give a little bit more
comfort and you want to amend the
wording of that condition
um as applicant we would be happy to do
so if that did have any any bearing as
well
um
but obviously the average age of
somebody moving in is 79 years of age
um you know you might get one or two
people at that lower end of the scale
but certainly
um the average age and substantial
surfing information is um 79 years of
age
thank you and so
what support so you this is a wide age
range and I imagine it's people of
different ability and disability
the people they say are these that if
somebody's requiring substantial amounts
of care they probably wouldn't move into
a development of this most people are
independent that they can get about
themselves you may get the odd person
who you know the internally
um there is you know level access uh
within the development and there is a
lift that provides access to all floors
of accommodation
um as well and there is one member of
staff there with the owner's Lounge
Etc but it isn't proposed that there's
not care as nursing care as such and
that you would get in a nursing home
which would be um for those type of um
occupants that would require that from
the offset
so to go on to the really this is
related to the parking spaces
um how many staff if we go with the
staff to begin with how many staff do
you employ on a in a development this
size how many staff would be on duty
there's one member of Staff who's there
during daytime hours
um Monday to Friday typically so that
would be like a care money a sort of a
manager it is yes to her yes so if
there's any queries
um you know they could read
directly with them outside of those
hours and the evenings Etc there is a
call alarm system as well okay
so we've got these people so I think the
if if your average age is 79 and a
non-driver then
these residents are going to have a lot
of visitors we found um in terms of when
people move in and a lot of people
obviously this is probably a more
sustainable site and than a lot of site
forgets in terms of proximity to town
centers
um compared to some of the other sites
um
it's in terms of the visitors there's
not you I think all of the evidence same
has been submitted with the the
application the highways report we don't
tend to find that there's you know
regular visitors and throughout the day
um all day every day
um Etc and that has been accounted for
in the traffic movements
um as well already in that in the
highways evidence
um for the numbers of spaces that's
required
um
I just feel that if you're starting to
put the age limit at 70 or the late the
FH base at 79 then this is an as I said
earlier this is an aging population
um
have you considered the visit Health and
Social Care visitors that might that
could visit actually yes that's
something yeah that's certainly
something which is accounted for in the
highway service which have been
undertaken
um to support the the evidence that was
put forward
um you know refers to developments
that's been operational
um so you know you would have the
visitors coming in you would have some
one or two people might have
um Care staff that might come in
um for an hour or two
um a day as well so that's certainly
been
um allowed for within the figures as
well
um obviously in terms of if somebody's
looking to to move into a development as
well it wouldn't actually be in the
company's interest to under provide
parking because that's something you
know somebody would obviously ask those
questions
um as well when they moved in and it
certainly wouldn't be in the company's
you know
um
you know position to under Supply car
parking and we're confident that we have
got this right and but in this case we
have um as your highways officer has a
ludacity we have provided in addition to
the 12 car parking spaces that they
survey evidence does
um provide and for so there's an
additional few spaces provided on top of
that as well there's also a buggy store
which is provided which we supplement
the parking spaces just to go back to
your
potential customers
you you just raised it yourself so if I
were I was purchasing one of these
apartments yes
and I asked for a parking space
would would that be it would be I'd be
able to purchase a a parking space
they're not allocated the parking spaces
um no
that could be a distraction really to
all these able-bodied people it's not
something which the company found that
is um something which is a detriment to
schemes Etc and as you see you know the
company are confident that they're not
right number of spaces have been
provided in this location
um thank you thank you thank you
councilor Lindsay
thank you
um
so
uh could you I I appreciate you don't
have the cost of the Flats at the moment
but um you must be able to tell us from
past experience
what sort of price range you've managed
to achieve perhaps in your most recent
development yeah I don't think the price
of the apartments or something which is
you know
sort of necessarily
um sort of reflective of the application
as well before you but yeah the prices
haven't been set as yet you say you're
meeting a need you see and the point is
there are a lot of old people of course
and more
um but a lot of people can't afford
private Flats with a a nice um Warden or
whatever it is so that's why I'm asking
that's why I think the price is relevant
yeah obviously the development is based
on this there's a high percentage of
owner occupiers
um
on a national and local level as well so
yeah it would be for somebody who's an
owner occupier rather than somebody
typically who's renting at the moment
um in terms of purchasing going forward
so born the hundred thousand I came to
Lindsay I think
all right so so I have two other
questions unless you're looking to move
in um I think you better leave that
subject for now
okay two other questions
um
the
well I think one's been answered
actually because a lot of weight has
been put on the benefits we have to look
at the benefits of this development for
public benefits
um because it is some of it's in public
space and there's a big argument to say
that all of it's on public space but so
the benefits
have been some of the benefits we said
to provide employment
I'm correct you thinking from what you
just said it's just one person
Gordon forward longer term obviously
there would be additional benefit in
terms of the number of construction jobs
that we've been provided as part of the
construction process which would be a
lot more significant in terms of
construction and the use of local
contractors Etc as well yes but of
course employment
the construction
be used to justify any
um
so and the other question is
[Music]
um
about viability I appreciate that
this Council seem to have
uh
um given developers of retirement homes
a free ride in terms of sale
and affordables
but presumably in other I understand in
bury Saint Edmunds you have a
development where you contributed half a
million
to West Suffolk
and other developments of yours I
noticed from I just did a quick search
yesterday you've got one in Haverhill
there's just two story seems to be
exactly the same footprint but only two
story they still have all the same
facilities
so this one will be four story having
much more people
for the same costs of employing one
person having a lounge and so on
um
so if you could have just asked would it
if you if you had to provide
affordables would it still be your
development still be viable
developed
at sort of you know considered on its
own merits each give us different in
terms of a lot of our sites may come on
and you know there aren't any Demolition
and obviously the sites are former
swimming pool which had been unfilled
and there's level constraints on the
site so there are a lot more issues in
terms of land Associated costs
um as well obviously the use we've
talked about of the use of high quality
materials here breaking the building up
and building materials obviously I think
everybody will be aware of have been
increasing substantially over the last
two or three years and so it's only at
any one point in time
um as well that applications are
considered some of the schemes which you
may be looking at will be on a
completely different site different site
constraints and different build costs
and different unit numbers Etc as well
but obviously the application before us
um today and the council's own evidence
looking at the site
um as well with the buildings it costs
as well Associated
um has been agreed and that will not be
valuable for affordable housing purposes
and and just supplementary perhaps one
of the objective objectives mentioned
the figure of I think they said 2.4
million profits from this scheme is that
can you confirm that or yeah I'm not
sure where the information came from
where that come from so
um
okay thank you thank you Council today
thank you just follow along from Kent so
McCann's question on Parkin
um you did state in your reply to her
that uh
majority would be independent and active
there so assuming that a couple aged 55
turned up there with a car each
will you when you get to 16
draw the line how will you do that
because uh obviously you've only got 16
spaces and at some point
if you end up with 30 people who've got
cars in there
what's going to happen yeah that that
situation would never materialize on a
site and just taking you back to you
said a couple moved and he were both 55
the lease does require as identified
slightly earlier that one the main
occupant would be um 60 years of age
partner or spouse 55. we don't tend to
get if somebody's got two cars you know
I don't think we ever have that
situation where you know people would
move in and people might not be ready
for that step in lifestyle change to
downsize if that's their own independent
um individual situation Etc but it's
certainly not happened on a site and
that I'm aware of and as I used to read
it before the company would only provide
enough spaces that they feel would be
necessary for the development of this
nature as well because you know people
just wouldn't move in if they didn't
think there was they had a car parking
space if they did have a car
um as well we find a lot of people
within the first 12 months find they no
longer need a car because obviously
there's the increasing costs to provide
cars to run and maintain cars it just
doesn't become cost effective when you
live so close to town centers when
you've got the shops and services on the
doorstep Etc
just follow an arm from that answer so
if you had 20 people move in and you
knew they've got cars would you then
tell the last 22 people there'd be no
point them applying if they want to have
a car there would you be talented
I don't think that's ever happened on a
development but somebody would be able
to see from themselves and how many car
parking spaces were used up because when
somebody comes and the sales Consultants
would obviously be open and honest with
people to how many existing
um occupants had cars and because it's
certainly a question people would ask
but it's certainly never materialized on
any of our existing developments that
everybody would have a car
thank you thanks for having me
thank you thank you chair
um can we have slide 21 up please while
I ask a question right
previously you said you couldn't have
any occupants in the flats while you
have a building site for the house can
you confirm that please because in the
um things they say that you you set up
to 15. but you said you couldn't have
any in
yeah I think in terms of a lot of The
Works to the house won't be heavy
construction vehicles that would be
required a lot of the internal Works
might be you know a bathroom fitter or
somebody coming to do kitchens which
would be able to be serviced you know a
Transit size vehicles that wouldn't
require heavy construction vehicles and
cranes Etc and to do a lot of the to do
a lot of that work
so what you're saying is you you will
have it says 15 on the restrictions so
instead of you saying you're going to
have 15
occupants in there potentially
potentially yeah potentially depending
on the time skills to do the works yeah
and saying that we would reach that
figure and but that's what we'd be
available
right okay
um while they're trying to get that one
on leave that one for it
how tall will the flats be from the
front end have you got a measurement for
us please
in terms of the flawed ceiling height so
yeah how tall will it the floor to
ceiling height typically is 2.7 meters
of um each of the floors
so no no sorry how tall will the actual
building I don't know if you're able to
I haven't got the exact um
right is this the one what's moves it is
isn't it right okay then I I want to go
more on the extension
um because because I'm going to ask a
question here
um with um why is the single story
extension being included on the side of
a house where the three 200 to 300 year
old YouTube stand
with one to be removed when there is an
existing
single extension on the other side of
the house what why is that so important
stepped down a huge tree a 200 to 300
year old YouTube which then you're
saying it takes over 30 years I was
saying it takes over 30 years to regrow
any substantial
so why why why can't
do the extension on the other side where
you don't have to cut anything down in
terms of some of the developments across
here I think it's already enclosed by
some existing
um Walling and so we are kind of
enclosing some of that Gap and to become
part of the build development form as
well
so you've already got an extension on
there so you're going to cut that down
so what else you can put in its place
the the tree I'm like to speak yeah the
the tree is being removed to allow for
the the main building departments
a little bit of extension on Bellevue
house is simply enclosing what is an
already open yard area so the wall is
already there
the tree does not sit inside that yard
that yard already exists or all we're
doing is putting the roof on it to
enclose it and make a part of the
building but then you're knocking down
what I'm saying is
another
another extension so why can't
why can't you build there instead of
knocking down a two to three hundred
year old chest
please right okay that we want to have
garden areas open space that that part
of the
State yeah yeah that is a very
unattractive extension
you can find it quickly please do
yeah so ask another question while
you're yeah okay all right what what is
the timeline for the house conversion
and then as a that's a part A and the
part B would be and what is the timeline
for the flats please
obviously it's assumed that the work
will be dunking currently at the same
time
um as well in terms of going forward as
well aims to have site staff on site and
at the same time it's certainly not the
intention to do the programs in
isolation as well so strictly speaking
the the work on Bellevue house will
start before
saying so so the the because
they're obviously building the walls to
create the site
we would expect that the majority of the
heavy work on Bellevue house would be
completed before we even start on our
part
that that's the way the program would
work because the Bellevue house is
existing it's not that work it's already
got current access so we would expect
that the the chunk of that work will
start before we start our building
that's the current program
so thank you
Council
councilor Hinton you were
Mr chairman uh two questions first of
all we've
T1 Flats
and the bedroom lava
it's a mix of um Apartments
bedrooms yeah
um in terms of
just get this
it was one person per flat it'd be 41
easy yeah but it's not the average
occupancy tends to be about 1.3 people
in per apartment on a scheme
um so you might get how many bedrooms
are there
just bear with me I'll just come back to
make sure I get it home percent right
for the what was changed
meantime Allison is this going to help
you ask your question
councilor I'm into a hill
so the tree in question
print off the
off so it actually would effectively go
right through the middle of the
trunk now you refer to couldn't the
building that's been demolished be used
to provide that accommodation
unfortunately the building that's
story extension that's being demolished
is that the Eastern end of Bellevue
house
which would be the two houses so it has
no relationship to the retirement living
accommodation in this block
so in order to get this building in this
position
because the building comes out to that
point
it does require the filling of one two
three possibly there's a fourth tree
simply because the building sits
on
Churchills
Apartments not not the Bellevue house
correct
okay Junction
do you want to finish your yeah well
the bedroom number was the first one
yeah and the other one is that uh you
mentioned
during your your presentation about the
the demand had been established for
quite a lot of older persons
accommodation Etc
bearing in mind that the ons said just
before the last census was actually
conducted that baber was the second
lowest growth area in the East Eastern
region with only 120 people extra in a
year and bearing in mind that the
government requires us to build 450
homes a year
and yet we have 4
900 and
sorry
4497 exact positions that have been
granted but not started yet uh where did
you actually find out this figure and
how many within our granted permissions
might be for older person occupation the
census figures that I read out to you as
um publicly available information that
came out and it was released in June um
June this year
um in terms of the data for older
persons and the overall figures as well
so yeah that was based on last year's
census which was just released in June
but it was older persons in
accommodation
accommodation
itself yeah by numbers so I would come
into that
yes
okay
it was over 65 the figure I actually am
cited
thank you Council McGraw you were cruel
you're gonna get the right one for one
day it's all right it's just a c or a g
they're not difficult
um going back to car parking because it
was suggested during the um
by officers that you might be willing to
consider a car sharing or a carpool as a
scheme to actually address I mean there
are 41 flats and getting a figure of 1.3
so we're looking at them and see if
somewhere pushing 60
and 16 car parking spaces I have to say
it still seems awfully small because
there are so many
um smaller Vehicles being used these
days people are being encouraged to use
electric vehicles
um and they are very suitable for
short-range travel
um so two questions really one would you
be willing to consider increasing the
number of car parking spaces could you
find would you be prepared to consider
and accommodate that and second a car
share a carpool scheme on the site for
the purposes of those residents
obviously you'd have to cost that out
but if that were to be suggested as a
condition would you be prepared to
consider it it's something obviously in
terms of car park management plan
perhaps
um you know we could provide information
in terms of that and the car share of
you know it's certainly something we
could put to
um you know the applicant
um if that was to be inserted as a
condition and the other thing I was just
going to
um be mindful of we have got the when
you see smaller vehicles with the
location the buggy the provision of the
buggy electric charge and Buggies is in
addition to the parking spaces as well
and where there is space for a number of
those are to be positioned as well as
the the parking spaces
okay
hop in quick consequences one just quick
on Mr chairman I did not note within the
report that he did mention
um defibrillator machines would you be
bearing in mind this is for the older
population with an average age of 79 uh
would you be prepared to uh install
ation machines yeah yes yeah I think the
answer to that is yes
that would be acceptable
transfer hope
this one question really in your
marketing for the site I take it you
would as a as a developer be quite
concise about the fact that there are
limited parking spaces and that anyone
buying the properties would be fully
aware of the situation regardless of
whether they had a car or not and that
any visitors they may have would also be
aware of that and that will be a
deciding fact on whether they were to
purchase the property leading on from
that the Town Center has adequate
parking for visitors and it would also
remind councilor beer that he was
certainly on the planning committee that
approved the Great Eastern development
which only provided three spaces for 15
Flats thank you
thanks thank you for that question
no you're only going to retaliate it
cancer Osborne
thank you Mr chairman I'm just um quick
one about the mobility uh situation you
have with the older residents that are
there I take it and I'm not uh and if
I'm wrong please correct me but
um you're going to have lifts available
in that in that area there is a lift
within the building that has access just
one left there is just one left on this
development I believe
yeah I understand that we weren't left
within the development yes
the other the other point of course is
um you are going to have an ability
scooters stored within that building in
those rooms I mean how are you going to
get over that for the healthy Mobility
Scooter area is actually external
um external covered area and within the
site
um on external without an external
um to the site
so they've obviously got um the ability
to walk the area of corridors that the
flats come off of
thanks and Karen
thank you sorry I'm coming back again it
was just no problem to me about the
lifts
um
whilst 40s three stories the high story
of four story I can't remember now it's
part three part four part four
this is a very elderly
or could be elderly population
well they identify with that cancer
um
what
has this does the County fire service
give you advice on because you've got
one left
on on the evacuation procedures for
residents
yeah
we do seek advice from the fire service
went to it but um
um councilor is correct it is normally
um regularized by the building
regulations
um which we would have to comply for to
make sure that there is a suitable
policy and going forward with that as
well and the turning head has been
tracked as well so a fire Appliance can
get within the site as well which is a
requirement as well so that has been
tracked as well
I'll just make a comment though as an
ex-regulator one person on duty seems
inadequate in the event of a fire so we
went for evacuating 41 Flats I'll just
make that as a comment thank you thank
you
well
no more questions
we'll work on because somebody's very
keen to talk to us one of the sound of
things
I think thank you very much indeed
thank you
um
we now have County councilor Jesse
Carter you've got to speak to us you
have five minutes to address the
committee and you can share that time
with your partner there or or you could
do it all yourself
you did it thank you very much sorry
um thank you as Savage County councilor
I believe I'm only permitted to speak on
County issues related to this hearing
um so I'll focus on highways today and
these views are not only my own but
those are concerned Sudbury residents of
whom I represent
uh We've Spoken a lot about the parking
spaces
um we know that they're proposing to
only Supply 16 parking spaces meaning
the proposed parking Provisions does not
Accord with the Suffolk guidance parking
2019. the populace of Sudbury already
struggle with residential parking and
this would add to the strain if over
half of potential driving residents were
not catered For
Churchill claimed that they have done
this because they believe their targeted
residents are at the age where the
majority will not have their own
vehicles but this is an alarming
assumption and in the likelihood that
they are wrong they have also not taken
into consideration any visitors that
residents might have and this could lead
care workers food deliverers taxis
family members Etc with nowhere to park
on site and will be left to find
on-street parking which will potentially
create an overflow that will spill out
onto Newton Road
there's also a distinctive lack of
disabled and emergency vehicle parking
spaces especially considering who their
target residents are
carrying on from this whether
where are the parking plans
for or access for residential dwellings
at Bellevue house considering the
potential traffic of emergency vehicles
residents race trucks maneuvering
electric buggies Etc careful
considerations should have already have
gone into this but it is absent in
evidence and therefore dangerous in his
lack of planning
regarding Crossings Churchill assumed
their residents will not be driving and
will either be using mobility scooters
buggies will be able to walk into local
amenities in the town however they would
have to access the town by Crossing some
of sudbury's busiest Junctions of which
are highly dangerous and are not
suitable to meet the disabled access
demands that Churchill are predicting
I had questions regarding to the 42 000
where it is being spent and other
councilors obviously have those same
questions
um I feel that whether it is spent on
um the Newton Road Crossings making them
more safe potentially widening the
pavement so that they're big enough to
to be able to fit these boys or Scooters
or whether it goes towards the
asteriskly proposed cornard road
crossing which is only at stage one of
safety checks and would still leave the
issues having to cross the Hazardous
roads with the race clip giving the
vulnerability of these residents and the
mobility issues how can the council say
that this is safe and accessible access
I would like to reference a recent
application in Boxford a housing
developer was recommended for refusal by
the planning officers because and I
quote this the scheme would result in an
unacceptable and severe impact on the
highway Network and its users without an
acceptable mitigating solution at the
same time Suffolk County Council
highways had no objections to the scheme
so in relation to the Bellevue proposals
we're discussing today officers have
repeatedly said that highways are not
injecting but this is in fact
insignificant
lastly I'll mention that we're all aware
that the sale of this site was intended
to fund the new entrance to Bellevue but
even these proposals are flawed with
more dangerous Junctions Crossings
little to no priority for pedestrians
and cyclists for this to go ahead would
be an unnecessary Hazard To those
wishing
[Music]
this application should be refused for a
number of reasons health safety
design dangerous highways but most
importantly because the people of
Sudbury do not want it they want public
land to remain public and for the little
open space Subway has left to be used in
such a manner
foreign
no thank you very much
I should say thank you twice shouldn't I
really
do with your
right we're now moving on we have the
ward member present
country as you have five minutes
oh we've got to wait until the sun goes
down
I'm sure that's
a song Somewhere isn't it
and the sand goes down
a bit hardboard while we're waiting
there are some cheese and Marmite well
see if anyone else
cancer heirs I've warned you before
about trying to bribe people in the
community
yes you may start
thank you thank you chair thank you
members officers
um for allowing me to speak
as a previous mayor in fact I've been
mayor of Sudbury three times I fully
support the present town mayor and the
residents the people in my ward
I listened to the people of Sudbury and
I'm speaking for the people of Sudbury
but I'm also speaking as someone who
lives in a purple residential home for
those who are not all 79 I might add and
have actually done some figures only 18
of our residents at Weaver's Court are
79 or over
the parking problem peppers I spoke to
our manager recently and she said
according to their magazine the Rouse
and the arguments over the parking when
there is insufficient parking and with
the maths I think it's only 37 parking
for the residents
totally you know unsuitable we have 63
parking at Weavers and they're still
problems
so you know that that is a real um thing
that I'm worried about
um and to consider that once you're over
60 or 55 is I find it quite insulting
because I am 20 years older than the 55
in fact I just had a birthday I don't
mind saying I'm 76. no way am I over the
hill I drive I do voluntary work
and um I walk a dog I I am very busy and
I drive my car because I have family who
do not always live in Sudbury so I need
my Independence and we're talking about
quality of life and these people who
purchase these Flats want quality of
life
I um the purchase price I I know it's
been um talked about but I know with
mine I pay 2 400 pounds a year for the
fact that we have a manager a gardener
and a window cleaner
I also pay
um 240 pounds a year for the ground rent
which I'm sure they would
um ask for and if when I pop my socks
and my family purchase or have my flat
they have to pay one percent back two
payrolls
of the actual value of the flat at that
time so I think they ought to be
considered
so you if you're on a basic pension no
way would you purchase one of these
Flats the other problem I have is that
those that are in mobility scooters and
we have two
but they have complained bitterly about
highways
highways and I would suggest that maybe
somebody from highways
with maybe some armor on would like to
try doing the streets of Sudbury with um
on a Mobility Scooter because the way
they are at the moment I would not go on
so the present figures I don't think are
realistic Sudbury is a town quite
different to the other towns
oh yes we do have we're close to the
town center so am I but there are also
people may want to go I love to drive to
the coast
I love to visit people in other places
so I think we've really got to respect
that they are not all 79 Plus in fact a
lot of our new residents are maybe 60 to
70 and they're all very active so thank
you for listening and please because I
do understand because I live in one of
those homes and the other thing I would
add I do have an area of garden and
gardening is so good for you of your
Health and Welfare as well
so thank you for listening
well I'll make a start perhaps I can
come back later
um
first of all I'd just like to go in on
the park inside of it again and the um
Road system around it I I think that's
all inadequate I just want to bring to
members attention that on the 6th of
September Suffolk County Council held
her we are listening
uh tent on the market Hill in Sudbury
and I attended it all morning
and uh
to my colleague at the back
the
new director
of uh highways growth and infrastructure
Andrew [ __ ] which I think is your boss
sorry and turned up and lots of the
public that came to the tent were
members from Sudbury all complaining
about Bellevue as amongst the other fins
and the we just made a decision on the
um
the entrance in Coronado road which
affects my population greatly
um and uh they were really complaining
it's unbelievable they thought the town
wasn't listening and what hopefully we
tried to explain the different
categories of governance to them but at
the end of the day that was the biggest
complaint we had
now Andrew cork
he um was new I say to him do you know
the area he said yes by the way he
couldn't get parked in Sudbury could not
get parked he parked in an hour space
which obviously he was running out of
because we were there four hours
and he had to go and move
and I said well I'd like to show you
this entrance in Bellevue
I said because I felt the highway
officers who have
come forward on this over the period of
time
um haven't understood it in my opinion
no disrespect to you
um Heaven understood the area and we
stood on the corner
and he saw the traffic
well I won't go into all the details
because that was the previous pattern
application for the entrance but what he
did say to me was that whilst he felt
that safety may not be
um an issue there because people crossed
the road enough to do things there
he did say and I'd like you to check
with him that the amount of traffic
along there in that area pedestrians
tried to cross the road and all the
others is very very difficult
and he acknowledged that uh and and I
thought that was very important
um now going on to this development I
think it's all over uh Mason I think
it's all too Mighty the
um the buildings uh it doesn't need to
be so full front there to the to the
public uh Bellevue house yes I think can
be uh revamped and redone and I think it
should have its own private entrance uh
actually
um certainly with the amount of lack of
Park and people coming there are going
to try to park in Barrett's peace Road
and those of us who live there know very
well and local councilors who are on the
Town Council should know as well that
you can never get parked there and you
live in that area so people uh visiting
this site would naturally go there and
try and park because you can't get
parked in the terrain either
um
the whole situation is really ill
thought out uh it's it's coming ahead
we're not sure whether we can get the
the
um entrance done prior to all this uh to
make it easier we're not sure that if we
do the dwelling at
um powerful house whether people will be
able to come in and out while all these
repairs and improvements and buildings
going on uh I think at the end of the
day
members you need to listen to the people
of Sudbury
they are adamant that this is not right
they're not saying that nothing should
ever be done
this isn't the right answer and uh I I I
will go as much as to say that we should
refuse this but I'll leave that for
others
um well it was a bit early in the debate
thank you thank you Council bill
anyone else like cares about
you come in here with a completely open
mind and very pleased with the
presentation that we've had from Vincent
which gave a really good oversight with
what we are looking to achieve I have
come to the conclusion that it's a great
opportunity missed by The District
Council
I think what we should be doing and I'm
I've got I've got scars on my back from
Bellevue
um
pretty much I'm very much was in favor
of the hotel development in the knocking
the house down Hotel development
Beefeater on the front which actually
did have quite a lot of parking spaces
provided interest enough for a
50-bedroom hotel
had probably about 40 or 50 parking
spaces interestingly enough
um again you know our policies seem to
have got set to one side
I have now come to conclusion seeing
this that
um Sudbury as a town the center of baber
would benefit from
a more
open approach from the district council
rather than a small gain in selling off
a passive land like this
and I think when the Matrix that was
produced originally by the economic
development team when I was running that
side
basically came down against the economic
argument for retirement it doesn't
generate income
you haven't got Big Spenders it's it's a
dead area especially when you put a dead
area next to a park where you've got
children a noise because I can guarantee
what we will be coming back to soon
would be complaints in environmental
health side of noise from the park
disturbing the residents of the 41 flats
that is absolutely what will happen we
will also have parking issues there so I
have
this is ill-considered I think it's it's
a shame that we've got to this point
um and I think the residents of Sudbury
deserve better I think an open space
the council has got the money in its
budget it has the two million set aside
which would be perfectly adequate to to
open up the space and there has been
some visuals and Graphics of that and I
think we should go with that so
I am certainly not a supporter of this
application
thank you counselor now here we go
thank you for this and yeah thank you
Vincent for a very very good um
founding thing
um yeah I've got loads of concerns here
um affordable housing
the open space which is is open space so
isn't it open space I believe it is open
space and the loss of the other it
doesn't matter how big the open space is
we're losing some of it
so and we can't afford to lose any open
space
loss over 200 300 year old YouTube I
can't believe no one's even thought do
you know what that's not a problem that
is a big problem it is a big problem for
our wildlife
um
the old swimming pool site you're saying
it's it's not Recreation well it's
Recreation this is what we had a
swimming pool in there we had a BMX
price in there we have never built on
that swimming pool site so why should we
now
um given all these issues and there is a
load of issues
I'm I'm not a supporter of this and I
believe that we should reject this
so when it comes to it I don't mind
putting it through or
counselor Lindsay
chair yeah
um
well I I'm
also grateful for the presentation
although I
I do feel sometimes we get
some of these presentations I know I'm
not I'm a substitute rather than a
regular Committee Member but I have seen
and been at committees where I think we
sometimes get over long and too Pro
developer presentations even though yes
I understand the officers are
recommending approval but um I think
it's up it's for us to decide
uh what we debate and how we're not not
the um the officer so however it was
useful to see the design and I do see
that the
and I I sort of applaud that this is for
getting a better
a bit better design
um but it's on a better design on
something that is still it's really
architectural tinsel
on what is a gesture of disrespect
to the medieval townscape
a Sudbury I really like Sudbury
um and and why I like it is because it's
got these little higgledy-piggledy
houses particularly uh King Street those
houses Range Rover it's it's got a charm
and you can read the history in it
um that site is Right bang overlooking
the church it's a really sensitive site
and we've got here a proposal for a
four-story building
right bang up on the road
uh sort of leering over uh what a great
two and grade one listed buildings down
King Street now I know you showed the
view uh a sort of mock-up of what it
would look like from King Street but
that was in the middle of the road in a
traffic Island most people won't see
that view because they're too busy
crossing the road the view people see
from the pavement
and actually if you're on the pavement
on the south side of King Street all
you'll see is this huge great four-story
thing
that has no meaning no relevance to the
history of
of of Sudbury
um there's a few little sort of things
that haven't been raised yet that I
wanted to to put in
that wall on the
that was like I'm interested to hear
that it was the the wall of the police
station I actually like that wall it's
got texture it's an old brick I really
like old brick walls and because of that
texture because of that history and you
you detailed how you know some of it was
the police station and there may have
been there's been some repairs and there
may have been raised the wall for the
swimming pool you can read the history
in it and that's what gives a town
meaning
um an interest and texture
um so to knock down that wall and
replace it with you know I saw the
mock-up it looked Twee and practically
meaningless in historical terms
so I thought I think you know this that
that wall is worth saving I think it's a
it's a history wall for for Sudbury
um and the other thing is about talking
about boundary treatments the the
um the Great
I I think the essence of the sort of
beauty of Bella View
uh Bellevue house and Bellevue Park it's
not the um
you know let's face it Bellevue house
it's locally listed it's it's a it's a
grand Victorian building it's fairly
bogged standard Victorian building
but it's the link with the with what was
the garden presumably and is now public
park with that lovely Terrace I can
visit people sitting if that was a cafe
people sitting on the top of the Terrace
looking out it and and you're not
severing the connection with with what I
mean the officer mentioned that it was
restoring the connection
uh between that Bellevue house and the
and the garden I think it's severing
that connection
um the suggested boundary treatments I
thought were horrific it removes all
historical meaning blocking the house so
the lower windows in order to give them
privacy
people using the park will have no
longer have access essentially to that
whole Bank
um
and and it becomes the park becomes
diminished as a result because the the
house is no longer part of the park in
in
um aesthetic terms
[Music]
but I think
the the other thing is the what we're
doing is plonking uh between 50 and 60
we don't have the figures but 1560
elderly people
on a site
right by
a mass of roundabouts Bellevue round
about you know I've tried I've have
trouble negotiating that roundabout on
foot it's it's a nightmare it's a
counselor and pointed out you've got to
cross there then you've got across there
then you got across there you know we we
should create try and create a town that
has easy routes through but there isn't
one on that site unfortunately and I'm
afraid that it's no use referencing
County council's vague plans there's no
certainty they'll ever happen I wish
they would but maybe when we've got a
safe Junction there then we'll allow
Churchill to come back and propose
something but there's no need for a
four-story
building on that site and so I propose
I'd recommend refusal
he said a proposal yeah
and you're secondly
fine or carry on with the debate
councilor hold
yeah thank you Jeff
um
this has been such a difficult site over
a number of years as council's will be
alluded to and it just amazes me that
every time something comes forward
there's always opposition to whatever it
may be whether it be a hotel or in this
case retirement living flats and we seem
to tiptoe around as I say accommodate
different views all the time keep
Bellevue house demolish Bellevue house
and
yet we're here today with a with a solid
planned application which I have to
commend the applicant for because they
have brought forward a scheme to me that
ticks a lot of boxes um and yet still
we're scrutinize it in the way we we
should and there seems to be members
here today that are just so dismissive
about it it does bring a huge benefit to
Sudbury with the increased retirement
living ability for the center of the
Town there's been a huge amount of
conversation about parking as I said or
tried to say earlier if you're going to
look at look to buy one of these
accommodations one of these units you
know what you're buying
you don't live in the town center with
one or two Motor Vehicles you tend to
live in a town center because you want
to get about by foot or by
disabled Mobility vehicle as well but
people who buy these know what they're
buying and yet we're still arguing about
car parking spaces because we believe
that people are going to move in with
two cars three cars but I just don't buy
that argument at all there is an
economic benefit to this because you're
bringing people into the center of a
town we have a great Network we have a
railway station bus station
good links to Colchester Ipswich Berry
and Braintree as well going across the
border it's a very sustainable site and
as I say I just find the negativity
about it is because there seems to be a
small opinion that the park needs to be
opened up in which case the council
leaves you lose your wall that you so
favor
um I just feel that we're looking at it
in a very blinked way or not in a
positive forward-looking way and
a little bit disappointed really to hear
views as they've been but um
I will
keep my thoughts myself a bit more and
listen hopefully to a bit more debate
because I feel that we're very short on
debate on this we seem to be going down
a very quick route of refusal but it'd
be interested to hear other members of
views because I certainly look upon this
as a very favorable application and will
be minded to support it
Mr chairman I do object to the previous
counselor Sam that we were dismissive I
certainly are not dismissive I represent
the people I represent in that area and
I encountered this every day so I do
know what I'm talking about along with
others thank you
thanks mikro
thank you I've had a lot of time
thinking about this and um
as the other members have referred to
it's uh scars on the back and possibly
from a different Viewpoint
um
and I've been considering all the
various aspects of the application for a
start it's considerably changed from
what I've seen previously I mean I say
considerably changed and some of it's
been small details some of it's been
larger details and people have been
making strong links about the two
applications to the entrance and to
Bellevue house and the former swimming
pool site and we consider each
application separately so it seems to me
that what we have to do here is yes it's
relevant that this might affect the
development of the entrance which I have
to say I voted for and I believe it was
a right to do so because I think Sudbury
and deserves a better opening an
entrance to Bellevue Park than the
existing hell hole that you actually
have because I honestly cannot
understand how the residents of
suffering been able to tolerate that
visual Scar the wall and Robert admire
so much I have to say I found horrible
um the graffiti I found
inadequately talented
um the
um General view of that end of Bellevue
Park strikes me is an absolute horror
and how people in Sudbury have lived
with that for 35 years or so that
Bellevue house has been allowed to
slowly fall into the ground requiring
regular upkeep so first thing is the
preservation of Bellevue house so regard
that as a positive benefit and I have to
say that nobody has so far come up with
an alternative scheme that has been
costed out and can be made to work I
know because I've dealt with it when it
went to kempt to council went through
scrutiny and everything else
secondly then the visual impact of the
proposals and I referred back to the
1926 View and how it would have looked
then which I have to say is fairly
standard early 20th century
here's a low here's a row of houses
obviously the black and white doesn't
flatter the view it would have been
further forward
um in terms of the general height impact
I'm impressed with the slope that comes
up that if you look at the line of sight
I don't believe it's as visually
unpleasant as has been in applied I like
the shaping and shading and and shading
shaping of the buildings
um the way that also flows into step by
step looking at that I think that's
actually much improved on some of the
earlier proposals which I have to save
were rather more in block form
so Bellevue house is preserved the
entrance position
um is supported but we have to we can
consider this application separately now
separately would this application stand
regardless of the entrance
and that's the question I think that's
before us today would it stand I have to
say I think the building itself would
say I am concerned about the parking
provision
but at this stage as a council that
we're obliged to take the advice of the
highways Authority
um whether we necessarily achieve it or
not it falls into the category of best
advice available to a planning Authority
which is to say us
the affordable housing is regrettable as
is the sill but that's the fact of life
that is the way that the policy is often
run in these situations and there are
many applications whereby we accept
stuff that is allowed in policy although
we may not personally agree with what
that policy states we have to accept
that that is what the policy states this
is allowable and legal and lawful
the general effect is Sudbury has had a
mess at end of Bellevue Park
um the the Bellevue Park
um environment coming down and the
Bellevue Bellevue house will not be
there if it falls down
and and within the absence of anything
proper to keep it standing up and use it
as an actual active building this is the
only proposal on the table it's the one
before us today we have a responsibility
to consider that along with everything
else
so I'm afraid on balance although I do
still have this reservation about the
parking and I would like a condition
maybe if it became possibly came up for
um some further examination of the
parking provision but I'm afraid I will
vote against the motion to refuse
thank you
councilman Busby you or ham was up there
okay it's
it's the option that we have on the
table it's not the only option that was
presented and it the future of Bellevue
house is not dependent upon this going
forward
um
interesting I'm going to try to take a
different slant to it to the majority I
think if you look if you look at the
documents that were on the website one
of them was the basing Stoke planning
appeal
where Beijing Stoke Council
and members I presume refused
a Churchill application which went to
appeal
now it's interesting to see why
the inspector then overturned Beijing
stoke's decision to refuse it
and the key elements were
they haven't got a five-year housing
Supply
what we have
yeah
that's so despite of that there was a
need for this type of housing according
to the inspector we don't know that
there's a local need for this type of
housing there
was a substantial contribution to the
provision of affordable housing
well we're not getting that here either
it was on the Redevelopment of
previously developed land
concert you know I don't believe that
we're really
redeveloping the land here
um
the local economy would benefit through
the generation of jobs
one job I mean really we go into all
this trouble for one job
so the key reasons for the inspector
overturning the Beijing Stoke decision
aren't relevant for us
and I don't know why that document was
put into on there but if it was to
attempt just to suggest that we
shouldn't turn this down because it
would go to appeal and get overturned
well I don't think that's the case
because I think all of the factors that
related to Beijing Stoke don't relate to
us
and just as an aside
um
I think the decision for me was
crystallized on on Monday at the Queen's
funeral uh I presume most of you watched
it there was a pro there was a point I'd
watched it for two or three hours and it
was unbelievable
and they just got to the Wellington gate
where they were going to transfer the
the coffin to the hearse to go to
Windsor
and the backdrop you've got all these
people that had marched all the way
through London
formed on the green and the backdrop was
a concrete and glass 70s five-story
six-story building and it totally threw
it and for me it was the worst moment of
the day and I thought that just typifies
what could happen here
got a park it's supposed to be somewhere
special it doesn't need to be surrounded
by high-rise buildings which totally
take away the meaning of the park it's
supposed to be tranquil it's supposed to
be bring a piece of the countryside into
the town if you've got a five or six
story building on the edge of it it
totally killed it
for that reason that I won't support it
okay
Jameson macfarinets
uh
since I became a counselor in 2019 this
has been sort of rumbling on and
probably years before that
what I find difficult
is the lack of affordable housing in
this scheme
any other applicant would be required to
do that
and here we have contention between the
Town Council and the District Council
and I just feel sad
that as we're the owners of the land
that we didn't think through what might
be helpful to the people of Sudbury and
I certainly think affordable housing
would have given something back to the
people of Sudbury and that is the
biggest problem for me in this
application thank you Jack thank you may
I remind some of you that you may
remember the planning applications with
no provision for affordable housing are
not a new or subject you know I remind
you of walnut tree the hospital
Redevelopment there were no affordable
housing there and also Saint Leonard's
when that horrible hospital was kept and
redeveloped so it is not necessary
sorry
only half there
it's a lot it's a long story which I'm
not going to test you
no it was something else long long time
ago
um
most of my brothers were born there and
it's it's the sort of situation where we
we're going round and round around in
circles and we are forgetting that some
of the things that have happened before
but never mind
Council Osborne and you were next in
line
thank you Mr chairman first of all can I
just thank
our our planning officer
for sex and presentation
regardless of what others might think I
I really appreciated all the effort that
he put into this not just this one but
the previous one as well that he he did
I completely concur with with councilor
Holt and councilor McLaren as mccrroll
on on his uh comments on this
I have
not lived all my life in Sudbury but one
of the one of the problems that I've
always faced and that of anybody that's
on council at Sudbury is the lack of
getting things done for the benefit of
Sunbury this is a benefit and it all
says it from uh Paris 919 down to 90 two
and quite kind with you I think it would
we've got to get something done you
can't keep refusing applications
on every single time and I might just
like to make the comment that
you've got a minority and you've got a
majority in Sudbury and it's not always
the majority that actually gets the same
so as far as I'm concerned I'm not going
to explore a sport or refusal on this
thank you thank you Mr chairman
Council hint
your turn
thank you
you don't wish to okay fine cancer Owen
yeah just reminding everyone there was
800 odd signatures on this you know it's
not a small amount
um and the you know the people that we
meet in Sudbury
are the people we actually go around
talking to and they're the ones who says
about
the beautiful Park and you've got to
remember while standing in the park you
can see how beautiful Saint Peters is
from the park
you wouldn't be able to do that if that
building was there
um and when you stand up buy some Peters
all you'll see is Churchill
buildings there
so you know you you've just got to see
what the people of Subway want to see as
well
Council
she's coming I'm not quite sure that uh
comment that you wouldn't see some
Peters if the Church of development was
built is actually true from all the
pictures and and diagrams we've seen
that Park Hendricks will be a clear view
up to Saint Peter's so I'm not sure
that's true the 800s if you can just let
me finish please if you wouldn't mind
counselor thank you very much indeed if
you have some manners thank you also the
800 signatures that she has mentioned
I'm not sure if all of those were
Sudbury or even great cornard residents
who are in a separate uh boundary award
to um Sudbury
um
I hadn't seen the basement papers I
wasn't relevant I wasn't aware that they
were in our papers as such um they were
on the website oh right I'd just say
it's been interesting if we've all had
the opportunity to see them
um
well perhaps I've looked on the website
but I use my papers as the relevant
documents
it's just
how frustrating as I say to hear these
arguments
um put forward to basically store this
development and store the site yet again
and I do find that um those who claim to
live have lived there for many many
years seem to be ignoring those that
perhaps haven't lived there for so long
it's it's not all about the old views
that count it's about new views and new
approaches to evolving Sudbury and
developing it into something we can all
be proud of all of us that is can be
proud of in the coming years
we need
investment we need change we need to
build and present Sovereign a much
better way than it is at the moment we
have lack development and change in
Sudbury for so many years it's something
that Baba should really be ashamed of to
be honest because it's lacked investment
and also from the County Council as well
and our County councilors may take note
of that that they seem to be able to not
get investment in suffering so I do feel
that we need to look at the much broader
picture
yeah just gonna suggest that um when you
think about it this was babe roned it's
a baby owned the house
babe was the one who let this go the way
it's gone
babe Ron the old swimming pool site
they could have done something a lot of
years ago it's not Sudbury town it's
baber and everything's Bay Brown and you
know that Michael you know my babe wrote
that
sorry else and I think you know better
than that okay to make that sort of
statement don't make a personal it's
another point to me I want to point a
clarification I believe councilor Alice
um Owen said from the park she didn't
say from in front of the new entrance so
the view from the park that's when
you're inside it and you stand looking
but then those who don't live locally
wouldn't know that
um but as for County councilors you
heard the subgroup clarity counselor as
well as myself who objected to these and
Highway issues and parking issues and
the list could go on so we we are on the
ball we are listening to the public and
I wish some of you others would listen
more too okay thank you let's have no
came to yeah we can't councilor Lindsay
yeah thank you chair I just wanted to
correct uh councilor Holt saying that
there's there's no evidence that it'll
affect the views of the church
um page 54
9.18
the third this is the Heritage team have
come up with this
um the third bullet point if you're
liking italics a low level of less than
substantial harm to the significance of
the church of Saint Peter grade one
that's a proposed apartment block would
likely obscure or else draw attention
away from a good view of this listed
building from Bellevue Park oh it's
there in Vacaville
thank you councilman McCrory you were
the only problem is that the same
paragraph 918 at an earlier paragraph
States something that's almost the
opposite which is a very low to low
level of less than substantial harm to
the bear hotel and at the end of it says
I consider there's a very low level of
harm would occur to the other grade two
listed buildings along King Street
listed below for the same reasons
gradually decreasing to no harm before
reaching the church of Saint Peter so on
one paragraph from the Heritage team we
have decreasing to no harm before
reaching the church of Saint Peter and
then the third paragraph the third
paragraph seems to say the opposite I'd
have to say I think this is a bit
subjective from the same person yes
yeah
if everybody has finished
and making any comments
then I will ask
councilor Lindsay what his motion is and
the grounds
and will you get the agreement
yes he does
so the motion is to refuse
um
on the grounds of the impact uh on on
the townscape and the conservation area
and the Heritage assets
um
to agree yeah and the the design of the
building and the the um the height
um
uh and and also the yeah I mean
I'm not convinced about the open space
argument
sorry no
the benefits of the we have to show that
there was a bent that's uh benefits that
outweigh the harm even though it's uh
less than substantial harm it's still
serious harm it says we have to show
what those benefits are I don't think
the benefits outweigh the harm that it's
caused
um
the benefits the local economy one in
one person employed
no yeah no affordable housing or sale
um the older persons it's only for older
persons that can afford it
um
okay yeah do you agree
I will get the Chief plans to read out
your proposal
if I can just
stop you there I need if this is to be a
reason for refusal and I've heard what
councilman Z has said
um you need to identify the reason in
more detail for me to take away that
on it if it's that
should we have a vote first sorry
chairman no we're trying to just say I I
have put a recommendation on the table
therefore I am committed professionally
to the recommendation before you so from
my perspective I'm trying
please please
let him finish so
so
you wish to delegate those powers to me
then that's one thing and you need to
say so I don't have that as a proposal
at the moment the proposal is which is a
reason for refusal I need to identify
the reasons we talk about affordable
housing I need to understand that and I
need to understand that in the context
of the evidence that is on the
application so this is not
this needs to be beyond my
evidence that leads you to that
conclusion I've seen too many appeals
where counselors in committee have
decided applications on the basis of
they're very strongly held opinion and I
accept that so when you put this in
front of a planning inspector and surely
we all will you will need we will need
as a council to defend that with
evidence
so
we started off with a an impact on
townscape which I I have some notes
around I would expect to uh
understand a little of the policies that
councilor Lindsay is praying in Aid
as regards affordable housing I would
welcome clarity as to what evidence is
drawn that is not presently available in
the papers and the evidence base that
leads to
a reasonable ask in relation to this
and in relation to the parking
I have heard what members have said
there is a judgment to be called
um
my experience of providers of this sort
of accommodation
are able usually to fight and defend
their appeals very successfully on the
ever
and most councils have very little
evidence that they can pull which
demonstrate demonstrates to the country
again we are back to evidence I think
you've heard from my colleague Mr
Chester and I doubt Mr Chester is going
to wish to defend a refusal on the
grounds of parking
heard the debate I've heard the
discussion about that issue
but again if officers are going to
reasonably defend this as a refusal
they will need to be able to draw upon
the evidence which leads the conclusion
and not the opinion that there is not
enough parking because we have advised
you on professional circumstances and I
am telling committee that I have seen in
other cases enough situations where the
evidence of providers of this sort of
accommodation are able to demonstrate
balance of probability that their
parking provision is reasonable
because
that motion fails and we wouldn't have
to go through this palava so it's surely
better to go over the vote to find out
what the vote is if the vote is in the
refusal then we need to go into that
detail because what I feel is happening
here is there is a direction from the
chief planning officer try and redirect
various people's thoughts in this
process and that I would suggest that
we'd be better off going for a vote if
the vote failed then obviously the
recommendation would then have to be
voted to approve but the way that the
chief planning officer is portraying
this at the moment is also directing
members to how to make a maybe a
different decision sort of pressure I
would suggest thank you for your comment
thank you
councilor crawl would that not rather
imply that um councilor Barrett is
suggesting that the planning officer uh
say what you want someone else can I
suggest that Mr Dupree gives us a sort
of a legal field procedural view yeah it
clearly is an important to me
the question is the question is what how
can people vote if they don't know what
they're voting for well
they are careful I
canceled it
I said what I was about to say in a very
admirable non-technical way this as a
matter of law if you're refusing
planning permission you must give
reasons for it
is not quite with the same with with
approval you don't generally have to
give reasons under the court
when you're following the officer's
reasoning if you are going with it but
it's
need to know at least in Broad terms Mr
Isabel and Mr Pierce need to go away
from here if the resolution to refuse is
successful the officers need to go away
and draw up a a
refusal
and then if there's an appeal the
officers need to think about defending
it and to put into effect the Democratic
will of the majority of the committee if
that's what's happening so we do
reasons for refusal at least in
reasonable outline
small pieces
one moment
you're the question of the legal
opposite
um
okay I'm gonna try and suggest some
okay
can I can I make a suggestion that the
poser and secondary get together while
we have a recess with the chief planning
officer
discuss what they might feel with the
grounds would be otherwise we're going
to we're other ways we're going to end
up parking this agreed
so I would I would suggest
the proposal and the secular
have a moment with the chief only
opposite while the rest of us have a
break
I'm going back
welcome back everyone
who's going to make the commenting I
asked um Chief planning officer to read
out what we've come up with okay
hopefully what will be supportive by all
members thank you uh chairman if I may
um so there are two reasons for refusal
proposed together with a delegation to
finalize a further uh reason so I'll
read this
um
out in full so the proposed retirement
living building would be unduly dominant
and its massing scale and location would
unacceptably impact upon the heritage
setting of grade two listed buildings
and undesignated Heritage assets within
King Street and the great one church of
Saint Peter causing less than
substantial harm to those assets to the
detriment of future Generations
proposed retirement living building
would moreover cause less than
substantial harm to the character and
appearance of Sudbury Conservation Area
by reasons of its scale massing and
location on that basis the application
will be contrary to nppf paragraph 202
saved local plan policies cno1 CNO 6
cno8 and core strategy policy cs-15 so
that's the first reason for refusal
chairman the second
the application and accompanying
evidence fails to demonstrate that the
provision of a contribution towards
affordable housing within the scheme
proposal would render the development
unviable the absence of such
case-specific evidence and viability
information precludes the council from
assessing whether policy cs-19 of the
baber core strategy has been satisfied
and it is not considered appropriate to
rely upon the general evidence
information relating to a development
plan which is still being examined on
that basis the absence of a contribution
or inclusion of affordables is
unacceptable and contrary to policy
cs-19 and then thirdly in relation to
the delegation delegate to the chief
planning officer to finalize the above
mentioned reasons for refusal and to
repair a reason for refusal related to
the loss of tree preservation ordered
trees
that's it you've heard it
now
I started to vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress you are voting for or
against refusal of the application
councilor beer I'm voting for thank you
councilor Lindsay
council department can I take yours
hmm
thank you members that is six votes for
refusal and five votes against
right
that's the decision
I will defend the meeting
closed and remind you that the next
meeting is on the 5th of October and the
meeting is over thank you